GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME
TO TODAY'S SUNSET OVERSIGHT
HEARING WHICH IS BEING HELD
JOINTLY BY THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON BUSINESS
PROFESSIONS THE ASSEMBLY
COMMITTEE ON HIGHER EDUCATION
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS. AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT AND THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION.
A FEW LOGISTICAL ITEMS ABOUT TO
TODAY DUE TO THE CURRENT STATE
AT HOME ORDER WE ARE PRACTICING
PHYSICAL DISTANCING HERE IN THE
CHAMBER THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. SOME MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WILL BE PARTICIPATING
VIRTUALLY TODAY VIA WEB
CONFERENCING TECHNOLOGY AS WILL
WITNESSES LISTED ON THE AGENDA
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO TESTIFY REGARDING
TODAY'S ENTITIES BEING REVIEW
TODAY. WE'LL BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE THE
CALL NUMBER. THAT THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS.
877-692-8957 AND THE ACCESS
CODE IS TWO FOUR. TWO SIX TWO
THREE SEVEN THE OPERATOR ON THE
LINE WILL GIVE YOU INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW TO BE PLACED IN THE
QUEUE BASED ON- THE ENTITY FOR
WHICH YOU PROVIDE WHICH TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY WHICH TODAY
IS. A BP WE ASK THAT WHEN YOU
CALL IN PLEASE LIMIT ALL
BACKGROUND NOISE. FOR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND WITNESSES
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY TODAY
PLEASE NOTE THAT YOU BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR MEETING AND I'M
MEETING YOURSELVES. AS
MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY TODAY WILL
BE SUBJECTING TO THE- BUT BASS
DANTE SUBJECT TO THE CENTER
REVIEW THE BUREAU FOR PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION. LIKE
TO THANK OUR COLLEAGUES CHAIR
ROTH CHAIR LEYVA AND SHARE
MEDINA FOR THEIR PARTNERSHIP
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS AS
WELL. HAVING SAID THAT NOW TURN
THE MIKE OVER TO SENATOR ROTH
FOR ANY COMMENTS YOU'D LIKE TO
MAKE. HER THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR I JUST APPRECIATE. BEING
INCLUDED IN THIS PROCESS AND
LOOK FORWARD TO THE
CONVERSATION. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NOW LIKE TO ALSO TURN IT
OVER TO A CHAIR LEYVA FOR ANY
OPENING REMARKS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR I TO LOOK FORWARD
TO THE DISCUSSION THERE'S
ALWAYS SO MUCH TO TALK ABOUT
WITH THE- POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION AND EXORCISTS ART
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THEN NOW FINALLY AND LAST
BUT NOT LEAST A CHAIR MEDINA.
THANK YOU CHAIR. I DO HAVE SOME
REMARKS THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
SHARE- SUNSET REVIEWS AN
IMPORTANT TIME FOR US IN THE
LEGISLATURE. IT'S OUR
OPPORTUNITY TO CHECK. IN ON OUR
REGULATORY AGENCIES REVIEWS
THAT THE HIGHS AND LOWS. AND
DETERMINE HOW WE WANT TO
PROCEED MOVING FORWARD. THIS
REVIEW IS A FUNDAMENTAL
OBLIGATION OF THE LEGISLATURE
AND A SACRED TRUST GRANTED TO
US BY THE PEOPLE. WE ARE
ELECTED NOT ONLY TO PASS
BUDGETS AND CRAFTS LAW. BUT
ALSO TO ENSURE THAT THE
MECHANICS OF GOVERNMENT ARE
FUNCTIONING IN A WAY THAT
BREAST SERVES OUR STATE.
INCLUDING THE REGULATION OF
VERY BUSINESS ACTIVITIES AND
PROFESSIONS. THE BUREAU OF
PRIVATE POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION HAS THE CHALLENGING
ROLE OF EXISTING IN THE
REGULATORY SPACE BETWEEN
LICENSURE AND EDUCATIONALISTS
AS HE- IS THIS AN AGENCY THAT
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR AUTHORIZING
A BUSINESS TO RUN WITHIN THE
CONFINES OF THE LAW. OR IS THIS
AN AGENCY THAT HELPS TO PROTECT
AN ADVOCATE FOR THE STUDENTS
AND ENSURE THAT THE ISSUES ARE
INVESTIGATED ADDRESSED AND
RESOLVED IN A TIMELY MANNER.
CAN IT DO BOTH EFFECTIVELY BP
HAS BEEN TASKED WITH THE
DIFFICULT WORK SINCE OUR LAST
SUNSET WE CLARIFIED OUR
EXPECTATIONS FOR THE BUREAU IN
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND AGAIN
THROUGH THE LEGISLATION THESE
PAST FIVE YEARS. I BELIEVE THAT
THE BUREAU HAS MADE PROGRESS
TOWARDS MEETING THE ISSUES WE
PRESENTED. YOU HAVE. THE BUREAU
HAS DRAMATICALLY DECREASED ITS
BACKLOG OF COMPLIANCE AND
COMPLAINT INVESTIGATIONS. WHILE
ALSO STANDING UP. OZAR AND
RESPONDING TO SEVERAL HIGH
PROFILE SCHOOL CLOSURES THE
BUREAU SUBMITTED A SUNSET
REPORT WITH RECOMMENDATIONS AS
TO HOW THE BP CAN TAKE EARLIER
AND MORE MEANINGFUL ACTION TO
PROTECT STUDENTS AND THE STATE.
I APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT THE
BPP HAS DONE AND WHILE THE
LEGISLATURE HAS OFTEN HAD CAUSE
FOR CONCERN I WANT TO BEGIN
TODAY BY RECOGNIZING THE
EFFORTS OF ALL THEBUREAU STAFF
WHO WORK TOWARDS IMPROVING THE
BPP. STILL WE MUST LOOK TO THE
FUTURE AND ACCESS HOW THE B. P.
P. E. CAN BEST SERVE THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA I ALSO LOOK
FORWARD TO OUR CONVERSATION
THIS MORNING THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH YOU'RE MEDINA
WILL THEN GET INTO A TODAY'S
TESTIMONY JOINING US TODAY AS
PRIMARY WITNESSES ARE THE
DIRECTOR OF DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS THE DEPUTY
BUREAU CHIEF AND THE CHIEF OF
THE OFFICE OF STUDENT
ASSISTANCE AND RELIEF. WE'RE
ASKING THAT WITNESSES LIMIT
THEIR OPENING REMARKS TO NO
MORE THAN THREE MINUTES AND
THEN WE'LL BE TAKING QUESTIONS
FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND THEN
FINALLY OPENING THE FLOOR TO
PUBLIC COMMENT WITH THAT SAID.
IS PRESENT WHATEVER READY. GOOD
MORNING CARILLO CHARACTER LEYVA
ACTOR MEDINA AND MEMBERS AND
KIMBERLY KURT MEYER DIRECTOR OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS JOINING. ME TODAY IS
LEGAL WORK RIGHT HE- CHIEF OF
THE BUREAU PRIVATE OKAY
EDUCATION AND THOUGHT WELL
PARTY FROM THE OFFICE OF
STUDENT ASSISTANCE AND RELIEF.
WE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT THAT THAT BEER
OFFER PRIVATE SECONDARY
EDUCATION TODAY. NOT WITH A
VISUALLY TODAY BUT JOINING THE
PARAFFIN IS THE NEW PARAKEETS
DEBORAH COCHRAN. AS THE
EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE ACCESS
AND SUCCESS NO POP INTO THE
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED EXPERTS
IN STUDENT AID AND HIGHER
EDUCATION POLICY. WORKING WITH
STATE AND FEDERAL POLICYMAKERS
SHE HAS FELT STATEWIDE
COALITIONS THAT DISTRICTS AND
STUDENT PROTECTIONS. FOR
EXPERIENCES FONG LEADERSHIP
WILL BE INVALUABLE. FOR THE
PAYROLL IN THE YEARS AHEAD.
YOUR PROVIDE OVER IN THE
FEATHER IS FACING OPERATE STAND
FOR QUITE AT THE- IN. INCLUDING
DID IT COME. AND INSTITUTE
PROVIDE AND I AND GIVING US
VOICE TO TAKE. IF YOU'RE ALSO
ABOUT VIOLATIONS OF LAW. AND
UNLIKE THE CAN BE AN ALL MAN
THE TUITION. FUND OR STRIP. THE
BUREAU HAS WORKED DILIGENTLY
AND MAKE GREAT THE BILL O'BRIEN
RIGHT ACTIONS PROTECT STUDENTS
THE GIRL IDENTIFIED BEEN FOR WE
ARE GOING TO SAY IN A SENSE FOR
UNIT WHICH HAS RESULTED IN MORE
THAN FEW. PER AND IN. ISSUED
THANK THE LAST MONTH REVEAL. IN
ADDITION NUMBER OF COMPLAINTS
INSPECTION DOUBLED TWENTY EIGHT
TO TWENTY AND PENDING CASES
HAVE DECREASED MORE THAN
SEVENTY FIVE PERCENT. ANOTHER
AREA I WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT
IS THE OFFICE OF STUDENT
ASSISTANT AND RELIEF OR- FAR AS
WE CALL IT. THE ROLE OF ALL
STAR IS TO ASSIST AND ADVISE IT
IS WITH REGARD TO COLLECTING
DOCUMENTATION TRANSFERRED OUT.
INFORMATION ON FEDERAL LOAN
GETS CHARGED PROGRAMMED IN
AFTER. THINGS THAT STRESS. THE
OFFICE WITH STAFF AND EIGHTEEN
TO PUT AT CLOSE TO SIXTY- SIXTY
THREE. CALL WHERE. WHICH ARE
FOLLOWED. BY ONE ON ONE NON.
STYLE ASSISTANCE TO OVER
SEVENTEEN. EMPIRE STUDENT FIVE
WILL. YOUR NINETEEN TWENTY A-
THE FED HAS OUT MORE THAN FOUR.
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS A PLAIN.
AND SO FAR TOO MILLION YEAR. I
AM PLEASED TO REPORT THAT THE
FIRST PHASE OF THE BEER OF NEW
AND INNOVATIVE IT MODERNIZATION
PROJECT LAUNCHES SEPTEMBER
TWENTY TWENTY WITH ALL
FUNCTIONALITY ESTIMATED TO BE
COMPLETED IN EARLY TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. THE NEW SYSTEM WILL
ALLOW INSTITUTIONS TO SUBMIT
THEIR INITIAL APPROVAL
APPLICATION FOR RENEWAL
APPLICATION AND THAT IT SEEMS
APPLICATION. ONLINE THROUGH AN
ONLINE PORTAL. PROVIDES EMAIL
AND TEXT MESSAGING APPLICATION
STATUS LOOKS THE APPLICANT.
ALLOW FOR ONLINE PAYMENT OF
FEES AND ENABLE INSTITUTIONS TO
COMMUNICATE WITH THE BUREAU VIA
THE PORTAL. UPDATED I SYSTEM
WILL ENABLE THE BUREAU TO MORE
EFFECTIVE IMPLEMENT RECOLLECTED.
AS. WELL I RECENTLY RELEASED A
FOR PARTY H SAID HE DID FACT
THE FUNDS HAD THE SEXUAL
BALANCED AND THEN YOU TO BE AT
THE INCREASE. THE DEPARTMENT
THE BUREAU OF WORKING THE
GOVERNOR OFFICE ALLEGES AND
STAY COOL. TO DETERMINE WHAT
STEPS NASA TO INTO PROPER FOR
THE ZERO. ALTHOUGH OKAY HAD
BEEN TO INSTITUTE FOR OUT WE
THE- IT HAS MAINTAIN THAT. AND
PROVIDE OUT READ TO SPEED AND-
SO MEDIA FIVE. THE WEBSITE AND
PRINT. IN VIRTUAL EXPO. LAST
WEEK PRIOR TO COPE WITH. ONLY
IF NUMBER IN FIFTY WERE TO SAID
TO CALIFORNIA STUDENT. AS A
RESULT THE POUND IN. THAT CAN
FOR IN PART TO DISCUSS.
LEARNING WHICH AFTER FROM IN
WORK. WORKING HARD TO ENSURE
TIMELY BUT THE BACK OF. I THANK
YOU FOR THAT OPPORTUNITY YOUR
PART AND NOT A YOUR STAFF AS
ALL WORK TO PUT AND PRO
STUDENTS AND WHAT THAT WE-
WELCOME QUITE THAT THE
COMMITTEE HAS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR NOW GO IN. A QUEST
FROM MEMBER AND FOR WILL BE
WITH S. M. MEMBER. THANKS VERY
MUCH MISTER CHAIR LET ME FOR
START BY THANKING HIM FOR
COMMITTEE- THAT HAD GATHERED
TODAY I THINK THIS IS
REFLECTIVE. OF HOW MUCH
INTEREST THERE IS. IN THIS
AGENCY AND I WILL TO SPEAK FOR
MYSELF BUT I THINK THAT MANY OF
OUR COLLEAGUES HAVE HAD THE
PERSPECTIVE THAT THE BUREAU OF
PRIVATE POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. IS IN DIRE NEED OF
REFORM AT A TIME WHEN OUR
STUDENTS ARE SUFFERING
IMMENSELY. COMPLICATED START
WITH THE TWO PARTS OF THE NOTES
FIRST- I WANT A CREDIT BUREAU
FOR ACTUALLY DENTAL FINE.
OBSTACLES TO FULFILLING ITS
MISSION AND PROVIDING
RECOMMENDATIONS TO US AND I
WANT TO JUST HIGHLIGHT BRIEFLY
A FEW. FROM RECOMMENDING THAT
WE CHANGE THE HARM REQUIREMENT
TO ENABLE THE BUREAU TO PREVENT
HARM TO STUDENTS PROACTIVELY.
REQUIRING SCHOOLS TO OBTAIN
SURETY BONDS TO COVER COSTS IN
THE EVENT OF CLOSURES.
RECOMMENDED THE AUTHORIZATION
OF THE BUREAU TO CREATE
STRONGER MINIMUM OPERATING
STANDARDS AND ALSO. POSING THAT
THE BUREAU GET MORE DISCRETION
REGARDING APPROVAL OF
ACCREDITATION I THINK THESE ARE
ALL REFORMS THAT WE SHOULD
ADOPT IN A VERY MUCH HOPE. IN
THIS PROCESS THAT WE WILL.
SECONDLY I KNOW THAT OUR DCA
DIRECTOR MENTIONED THIS BUT- I
WANT TO JUST- APPRECIATE
GOVERNOR NEWSOM FOR APPOINTING
DEBBIE COCHRAN TO. THE ROLE OF
DIRECTOR WE HAVE NOT HAD A
DIRECTOR. IN THIS DEPARTMENT
FOR A NUMBER OF MONTHS SHE HAS
BEEN A STRONG INDEPENDENT
EXPERIENCED AND WELL REGARDED.
VOICE FOR HIGHER ED STUDENTS
SOME HOPING THAT SHE'S GOING TO
BE CONFIRMED BY THE SENATE. NOW
pPERSPECTIVE I THINK MANY OF THE
CHALLENGES WE'RE DISCUSSING
TODAY. PREDATED THE NIXON
ADMINISTRATION AND REPRESENT
YEARS OF THIS FUNCTIONALITY AND
FRANKLY INDUSTRY CAPTURE. OF
THIS BUREAU SO MY FIRST
QUESTION IS AROUND- FOCUSES ON
THE FRST ISSUE RAISED AND A
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS. AROUND
ADVISORY COMMITTEE. IT'S WELL
KNOWN THIS BEER HOUSING
ADVISORY COMMITTEE THAT BY ALL
ACCOUNTS. HAS BEEN WEEK BY
NATURE. WITHOUT DIRECT
OVERSIGHT OF THE BUREAU WITHOUT
DIRECT VOTING POWER OVER
REGULATORY ACTIONS. SUCH AS
DISAPPOINTING OR CLOSING THE
SCHOOL. AND I'LL JUST NOTE IT'S
CURRENTLY LED BY AN ATTORNEY.
WHO REPRESENTS FOR PROFIT
SCHOOLS INCLUDING. THE
CORINTHIAN COLLEGES WHEN IT
CLOSED WHICH- STRIKES MANY OF
US AS THE FOX GUARDING THE HEN
HOUSE. I WANT TO ASK. THE
BUREAU. DO YOU THINK THAT WE
SHOULD BE EXAMINING WHETHER
THIS ADVISORY COMMITTEE SHOULD
BE REPLACED BY A STRONGER.
BOARD FORMAT WHICH IS MORE
COMMON. TO OTHER ELEMENTS OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS SAY THE STATE MEDICAL
BOARD WHICH CAN VOTE TO TAKE
AWAY. DOCTORS LICENSES. YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THAT. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO PAY THAT- AS
WE LOOK TO THIS PERIL. PLAY
VERY MUCH SENATE BY. ROLE AND
WE DO LOOK AT THEM GIVE US
GUIDANCE AND FOR MIKE
INFORMATION ON THE TOPIC BEFORE
AT. WELL THEY AREN'T AN ACTUAL
VOTING BODY THEY DO PROVIDE
THAT NEEDED FEEDBACK ON ON THE
INDUSTRY. ON SOME OF THE THINGS
THEY PROVIDE FEEDBACK ON OUR ON
REGULATIONS THAT THEY'RE GOING
THROUGH I'M LEGISLATION WE TALK
TO THEM AND GET THEIR FEEDBACK
ON LEGISLATION. I'M ALSO JUST
LOOKING AT BUDGET OPERATIONS
AND JUST THE OVERALL PROGRESS
THAT THE ACTUAL- ZERO IT TAKING
THROUGHOUT THE YEAR- THE
ADVISORY. COMMITTEE DOES PLAY A
VITAL ROLE IN PROVIDING BOTH
RECOMMENDATION. I'M AT THIS
ADVISORY COMMITTEE TO SET
IDENTIFIED THE ROLE HE'S
ACTUALLY PROVIDED A HANDFUL OF
THEM I'M KINDA LIKE A PROCEDURE
MANUAL THAT THEY NEED. AND THAT
WE COULD ACTUALLY LOOKED AT THE
ACTUAL DISCUSSION OF WHETHER
DENNIS ADVISORY COMMITTEE
SHOULD BE TURNED INTO A BOARD
SIMILAR LIKE OUR OTHER BOARD
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT BUT WERE
REALLY HAPPY TO. THINK ABOUT
THAT AND DISCUSS THAT WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND IF THAT IS-
SOMETHING THAT YOU WANT TO
PROCEED I'M DEFINITELY WE WANT.
TO LOOK AT THAT WE ACTUALLY
HAVE EVIDENCE ON THAT- ADVISORY
COMMITTEE AS WELL WE'VE JUST
RECENTLY APPOINTED A NEW-
STUDENT MEMBER. INDIVIDUAL THAT
REPRESENT STUDENT ON THE
COMMITTEE I'M SO WE THINK THAT
WE HAVE A BROAD. IMPACT FROM
THAT INDIVIDUAL GIVING US
DIRECTION BUT YOU ARE CORRECT
IT DOES NOT AFFECT THE SAME AS
IT WOULD IF IT WERE UP FOR IT
BUT IT IS SOMETHING WE'RE
DEFINITELY. I'M WILLING THE
FACT THE LEGISLATURE. I
APPRECIATE THAT I DO THINK IT'S
A WERE THE TOPIC OF-
CONSIDERATION FOR US- MY SECOND
QUESTION. ADDRESSES THE FACT
THE COMEDIAN ALSO SUMMARIZE
SOME OF THE MAJOR LAWS THE
BUREAU SUPPOSED TO OVERSEE.
WHICH HAPPENS TO INCLUDE ONE OF
MINE AB THIRTEEN FORTY FROM
TWENTY NINETEEN. AND TO REFRESH
OUR LAW WAS PROPOSED AFTER THE
TRUMP. ADMINISTRATION
ELIMINATED THE OLD BOMB AND
THEN. GAME EMPLOYMENT RULE.
WHICH FOUNDER ROBERT HUNDRED
FIFTH CAL PER. WERE NOT WELL
SERVING FIFTIES THOUSAND. WHO
ALMOST OF DOLLARS IN DEBT. AS
YOU MAY KNOW THE PROFIT. PER
THIS BILL. YOUR BUREAU ASKED US
TO WATER DOWN. AND SINCE IT.
NOW TWO AGO. IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE BUREAU
HASN'T PROMULGATED REGULATIONS.
HASN'T BEEN PROACTIVE IN DOING
OUTREACH TO SCHOOLS TO ENSURE
THE CRITICAL COLLECTION OF
DATA. SO THAT OUR STUDENTS KNOW
WHAT SCHOOLS ME GOING THEY MAY
BE GOING TO. AND I WILL ALSO
SAY AS A BILL IS GOING THROUGH
THE PROCESS THE BEER WAS
SUPPOSED TO AMEND. YOUR I. T.
CONTRACTS TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE BILL. ONE
UNDERSTAND- WHAT HAS HAPPENED
WHAT WHY HAVE THESE ACTIONS NOT
HAPPENED. ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHU
ADDS THAT THE BILL AB THIRTEEN
FORTY EIGHT SOMETHING THAT
THAT. THAT APPRECIATE. ACTUALLY
IT'S VERY SUPPORT OF THIS BILL-
AND WE REALLY WANTED TO MOVE IT
FORWARD. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE HAVE AND FEW SIP MENTIONED
IT'S THAT- BILL DOES REQUIRED
THAT IF THERE ARE IMPROVEMENTS
AND CHANGES IN THE CURRENT- I.
T. THAT IS OUT THERE. AND SO
WHAT WE DID IT WE WERE GOING.
THROUGH THAT- THAT WHERE OUR
BID MODEL. PROCESS WE KNEW THAT
WE ITSELF IN THE MIDDLE WE WANT
TO IN THE OFF. AND SO WHAT WE
AGREED TO THAT WE WOULD WAIT
AND THEY- ENTITY THAT THAT
OFFENDER AND THAT IN. THAT'S
BEING. TO THE BILL ON THAT I HE
SAID. ONE IT AFTER MET THEN WE
WOULD LOVE AT IN. THIS MODEL
AND I HAVE ACTUALLY ARE DEPUTY
CHIEF ALSO AT THIS AT THE TO
THE TWELVE BUT I WANT TO GIVE
YOU WHERE WE ON THE FIVE DAY.
SO THAT'S- WE ROLLED THE FIRST
STEP OF IT SEPTEMBER TWENTY- I
BET HAPPENED IT WAS TOO FAR IN
THE ADDAMS INFORMATION ON WE'RE
GOING THROUGH HERE AND
CONTINUING TO ROLL OUT IN
DIFFERENT PHASES INTENTIONAL-
ACTIVITIES AND IMPROVEMENTS IN
OUR IT SYSTEM AS YOU KNOW. THE
SYSTEM OF THAT ANTIQUATED
SYSTEM THAT WE HAD BUT IN ORDER
TO IMPLEMENT YOUR BILL WE DO
HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT
SYSTEM IS READY AND SO THE PLAN
IS DEFINITELY IT AT THAT- IF
THE INTERFERE WITH THAT I IS
ROLLED OUT. AND LIFE TO SEE
WHETHER WHERE THEY'RE NEEDED
AND THEN AT THAT POINT WE WOULD
BE LOOKING TO- GATHERED THE
INFORMATION AND IF WE HAVE TO
GO THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TECHNOLOGY- THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT WE MAY NEED
TO DO TO. PROVIDE A PROJECT-
DOCUMENTS HIT THEM- THAT WOULD
BE AT- SOMETHING THAT WE NEED
TO GET WERE HOPING THAT THAT IS
NOT THE CASE AND THEN AT THAT
POINT WE WOULD BE ABLE TO
EMPLOY. I'M AT THIRTEEN FORTY
EIGHT AFTER THAT MUCH NEEDED
INFORMATION AND I KNOW THAT AS
FAR AS THAT INFORMATION AND
PROVIDING INFORMATION TO STAFF-
MISTER ABOUT THIRTY ALREADY HAD
GATHERING SOME OF THAT
INFORMATION AND GETTING THAT
TOO. I'M GOOD AT- AND I WILL
ACTUALLY HAVE HIM ALSO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT THEY DO
WITH THE INFORMATION WHEN THEY
GATHER IT MR ABOUT FORTY IF YOU
CAN ALSO ADD ON TO THE. TO THE-
QUESTION- BUT THANK YOU FOR
THAT- SO IN IN- TO. YOU KNOW
WE'RE WILL WHAT AWARE OF YOU
KNOW THE THAT THE- YEAH. BE
UNINTENDED AND- OF WHAT
THIRTEEN FOR WILL GIVE. AND IN
THAT. IN AROUND THAT TIME TO
FILL. WE GET THERE TERMS OF THE
TECH. TO BE ABLE TO DO- THE
MATCHING IT CETERA. NOW WE HAVE
TAKEN UP FOR IN OUR COVERAGE
CONTENT. TO SPEAK WITH PERSON.
STUDENTS ABOUT I THINK THE THEY
CAN. ABOUT BE. TO GET THE NEW
PRE IN HOME DISCLOSURES ARE.
THE SCHOOL BUT- BAKSHI YEAH.
DOING- EMPLOY. SURVEY ACT THEM
YOU ARE. MANAGEMENT WITH A LOT
OF TOOLS THAT ARE ALSO- THAT
WILL. HELP THEM MAKE MORE IN.
DECISIONS AND A BETTER I. OF
THEY'RE- BURNING WOULD BE
INTEGRATORS. FROM THE HIGH
SCHOOL. THAT ARE- RESEARCH- WE
CONNECT. WITH LOCAL. WORKFORCE
DRAMATIC FOR. AS WELL. AND I DO
EVERYTHING CAN HELP THOSE
RESPECT STUDENTS. MAKE ONE OF
THE STATE WHICH WERE ONLY BE-
MORSE. BY OF THIRTY FORTY. AND
WE HAVE THAT. SO I'M LET ME
JUST WITH A CUP COMMENTS A THAT
FIRST ALL VERY MUCH OF. YOU
STATING THAT THE BEER IS A OF
THE EMBLEM OF OUR BILL I WILL
STATE THAT HAS FRANKLY NOT BEEN
THE EXPERIENCE OF OUR OFFICE.
AS WE WERE WORKING ON A BILL
MOVING THROUGH THE PROCESS AND
WE VERY MUCH WOULD LIKE TO GET
A FULL UPDATE OF WHAT'S
HAPPENING AROUND AB THIRTEEN
FORTY BECAUSE AGAIN.
REGULATIONS HAVEN'T BEEN
PROMULGATED WE'RE NOT AWARE OF
DIRECT OUTREACH TO SCHOOLS
AROUND DATA ANY ANY REFERENCE
TO DELAYS AND I. T. AND I JUST
ONE NOTE. AS AS YOU WELL KNOW
BECAUSE I SERVE IN THE BUDGET
SUBCOMMITTEE THAT OVERSEES-
BUDGET EXPENDITURES IN THIS
AREA YOUR APARTMENT BROADLY
SPEAKING DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS. HAS BEEN INCREDIBLY
CHALLENGING PERFORMING IT
MODERNIZATION PROJECTS AND I'LL
SAY THAT AS YOU KNOW THE
BUREAU. STARTED THIS
CONVERSATION CLOSE TO FIVE
YEARS AGO- BROWN MODERNIZATION
AND WE ARE STILL WAITING- AND I
APPRECIATE THE UPDATE TODAY ON
THE STATUS OF THE PLAN BUT- I
HAVE TO SAY WELL ALL EYES OF
THE PUBLIC AROUND EDT AT THE
MOMENT. FROM MY PERSPECTIVE THE
FAILURES OF IT MODERNIZATION
WITHIN YOU SEE A PARTICULARLY
IN THIS DEPARTMENT IS
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTING OUR
ABILITY TO TAKE CARE OF OUR
STUDENTS AND- I'M WONDERING IF
YOU COULD TELL ME HOW MANY
YEARS BEHIND. AND HOW MANY
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS A WEEK
BEHIND WHEN IT COMES. TO
MONETIZATION OF THIS PROJECT.
THIS PROJECT IT. YOU KNOW I
MEMBER TO I'VE BEEN WITH THE
SUPPORT ALONG TIME I READ. HERE
WE HAD- IT IT IS DIFFERENT PLAN
THE REPORT WILL ROLLED OUT AND
I KNOW THAT THOSE ARE SOME OF
THE ISSUES. BUT THEN IT PROJECT
I HAVE TO TELL YOU IS WHERE WE
LEARN FROM SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT IN THE PAST HAD HAPPENED
THAT WORK. LEARN FROM WHERE WE
CAME FROM BASICALLY. THEIR
ENTIRE BUSINESS MODERNIZATION
PROJECT HAS BEEN COMPLETELY
AGILE AND VERY DIFFERENT FROM
THE WAY THAT THE FIRE PROJECT
WAS PUT IN- WE HAVE
ORGANIZATION CHANGE MANAGEMENT
WE HAVE INDIVIDUALS THAT CAME
IN AND LOOK AT THESE PROGRAMS
AND HOW THEY WOULD GET. I HE-
TO MEET THE NEEDS OF THE BOARD
AND ZERO- FROM THE GET GO WHAT
ARE THE POSSIBLE TO LET HIM
PLAY THEY WENT THROUGH EVERY
PROPER THAT THEY LOOK AT
CHANGES THAT NEEDED TO BE MADE.
SO THAT I CAN LEARNING FROM
PAST MISTAKES THIS ENTIRE UNIT
FOR THEIR BUSINESS
MODERNIZATION FOR THIS
PARTICULAR GIRL HAVE BEEN VERY
DIFFERENT THAN ANYTHING ELSE.
ON THE DATE THAT I BELIEVE THE
TOTAL COSTS AROUND A LITTLE
OVER THREE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
WHAT HAS BEEN PUT IN FOR THIS.
SPECIFIC ENTITY- AND WE ARE ON
TARGET IT'S NOT BEHIND IN
SCHEDULE I KNOW THAT THEY WERE
PART OF THE PARADE THREE LEAF
THREE. BUT WHEN WE CHANGED- HE
SAID YOU TO THE GUIDANCE OF THE
LEGISLATURE WHEN WE CHANGE
PROFIT THEN WE DECIDED THAT WE
WERE GOING TO LOOK. AT THEM. AS
A BUSINESS MODERNIZATION
PROJECT THAT CHANGE THE WAY WE
WENT AND NEVER COURSES. AND GET
HIS REALLY BEEN FOR THE BENEFIT
OF THIS PROGRAM AND THEIR AFTER
AWHILE ROLLOUT THAT WE- HAD
ALLOW THEM AFTER. READ WE THINK
A LOT EARLIER THAN WE WOULD
HAVE BEEN THE PAST NOW WE HAVE.
WE HAVE- INDIVIDUAL TO DO UP
WITH. LOOK WHAT THE APPLE. FOR
AND END OF IT SYSTEM ONLINE.
AND THEN WE'RE RIGHT NOW- AB.
MY ALL OF THE IN. FROM THE OLD
ANTIQUATED SYSTEM THE NEW
SYSTEM DOING AB FOUR STILL WORK.
HERE'S FROM WHEN THE
CONVERSATION STARTED AROUND SO
CALLED BUSINESS PROCESS
MODERNIZATION. THAT TO ME
DOESN'T STRIKE ME AS AS ADULTS
LET ME JUST CONCLUDE WITH ONE
STATEMENT- WE RECEIVED A LETTER
FROM A BROAD COALITION OF
HIGHER ED. CIVIL RIGHTS
CONSUMER STUDENT AND VETERAN
AFFAIR. BUT BEEN ON ADVOCATES.
WHO PROPOSED A NUMBER OF
RECOMMENDATIONS- THAT I DON'T
THINK WE'RE DIRECTLY ADDRESSED.
IN YOUR ANALYSIS TO IMPROVE THE
STATE FUND. TO REQUIRE PROGRAMS
TO PREPARE STUDENTS FOR
LICENSURE OR CERTIFICATION IN
FIELDS. OR LICENCES AND
CERTIFICATES REQUIRED. TO
EXPAND THE DATA TO SUPPORT
CRADLE TO CAREER DATA SYSTEMS.
ANTM REMOVE EXEMPTIONS IN
NONPROFIT CONVERSION
PROTECTIONS. MY HOPE IS THAT WE
WILL BE CONSIDERING THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND- AGAIN
WOULD LIKE TO ASK YOU IF YOU
HAVE A PERSPECTIVE ON THOSE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT YOU DID
NOT INCLUDE. IN YOUR ANALYSIS.
YEAH WE WE'VE LOOKED AT THAT
LETTER AND WE APPRECIATE ANY
ANYTIME INDIVIDUALS ARE ARE
PROVIDING THAT WAY THAT WE CAN
IMPROVE OUR PROCESSES IS A GOOD
THING TO US AND SO WE REALLY
FIFTY TYPICAL LETTER FROM THAT
COALITION OF GROUPS. ON GET
SOMETHING WE WILL DEFINITELY
LOOK AT AND WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK
WITH THE LEGISLATURE AS WE
DEFINE AND I IDENTIFIED. WITH
ONE OF THOSE SUGGESTED
RECOMMENDATIONS MOVE FORWARD-
AND WE'RE HAPPY TO WORK WITH
YOU YOUR STAFF AS WELL AS ALL
OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF IN
MOVING THE THING FORWARD- ABHI
IDENTIFIED THE NEED FOR THEM.
THANKS VERY MUCH- TO THE
TERRORIST THANK YOU FOR
INTELLIGENCE. THE YOU SO MUCH A
CELL ONE FOR BY SEN MEMBER ME.
THANK YOU- MY COLLEAGUES SAN
FRANCISCO CHAREDI BONDS AND A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO I
INTRODUCED LEGISLATION AB
NINETEEN SIXTEEN TO REQUIRE
PRIVATE POST SECONDARY SCHOOLS
THE FIRE FILE A THIRTY BOND-
POSTED WITH B. P. P. AND ADAM
OUT COMPATIBLE WITH TUITION AND
FEES IMPOSED ON THE STUDENTS
AND THEN IN THE EVENT THAT A
SCHOOL CLOSES- IT COULD BE USED
FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS- GOING
BEYOND WHAT AS TO EUROPE-
COVERS COULD YOU PLEASE
ELABORATE. ON THE POTENTIAL
BENEFITS OF- AMENDING STATUTE
TO GRANT BPP THE AUTHORITY TO-
REQUIRE ASSUREDLY BOND. YES
DEFINITELY AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT WAS PLACED INTO
OUR ON PAPER AND PARCHMENT THAT
REPORT AS YOU MENTIONED AND SO
IT IS SOMETHING THAT WE LOOK
AT- WE THINK THAT THERE WOULD
BE A LOT OF BENEFITS TO IT AS
YOU KNOW RIGHT NOW IN AND OUT
HAVE METRIC READY ALSO- WEIGHED
IN ON THIS AS WELL BUT- AS YOU
KNOW RIGHT NOW THAT WE KNOW
FULL CLOSES THERE'S A LOT OF
DEBT THAT IS LEFT- AND RIGHT
NOW IT. WOULD BE THE BUREAU TO
THE MOST PART I'M THEIR
TRANSCRIPTS THAT THESE
INDIVIDUALS NEED TO BE ABLE TO
GET TO TRANSFER TO OTHER
SCHOOLS THERE'S MAINTENANCE OF
THOSE TRANSCRIPTS THERE'S
MAINTENANCE OF THE WHOLE RECORD
THERE'S HE FELT THAT NEED TO
HAPPEN- WITH THE STUDENTS-
THERE'S ALSO JUST BASICALLY
HAVING. AN INDIVIDUAL THAT YOU
CAN GO TO GET ANY OTHER TYPES
OF RECORDS WITH THE SCHOOL ALL
OF THE THERE ARE WE HAVE- OUR
STAFF TO ITS FLEET TRAVEL TO
THESE CLOTHES SCHOOL- TO EXCESS
ARE OLD PARKING GO DOWN AND
HELP INDIVIDUALS- WITH BEING
ABLE TO APPLY FOR STRIP CLEAN.
ALL OF THAT- IT IS BASICALLY
AND I'M ELEMENT THAT THAT FALLS
INTO THAT ZERO SO ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE RECOMMENDED IN
OUR- RECOMMENDATIONS OF NEW
INITIATIVES IN THE COMFORT
REPORT IS THE POTENTIAL FOR
HAVING A SECURITY BOND THAT
WOULD COVER A LOT OF THE SPOT
WE THINK THAT. IT WOULD BE A
BENEFIT WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO
COVER COSTS ANDNOT HAVE IT
COME OUT OF THE BUREAU AND IT
WOULD PUT THAT ON PAYMENT BACK
ON THE SCHOOL WITH ACTUALLY I
AM THE ONE WHO IS IT POPPING
THAT INDEBTEDNESS AND THAT'S
WHAT FREDDIE IF YOU. HAVE
ANYTHING TO ADD PLEASE ITSELF.
AND YEAH THANK YOU. DEFINITELY
THIS IS YOUR BOND WE BELIEVE
FOR. HELL THE STATE AND IN A
WAY THAT. IT'S THE WHAT. WE
CANNOT. DO AT THE PARK. OF
BEING ABLE TO ALLOW. AND I. TO
THEY ARE TO HELP DIDN'T. OUT
THEIR- AND- REPEAT THE RECORDS
THAT THEY TO RECEIVE A ORDER.
TO BUT ON. THAT WE WEREN'T ABLE
TO. GET UP IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
BUT THE- FINANCIALLY IT'S TIME
TO TRY AGAIN. THANK YOU SEVEN
ONE IRVINE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN FOLLOWED BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FALL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CARILLO AND I'D LIKE
TO- JUST SECOND THE COMMENTS
MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO AND FROM HER VENTURA
COUNTY- IN TERMS OF THEIR
CONCERNS THAT THEY HAVE ALSO- I
WAS EXCITED TO HEAR THAT- MISS
COCHRAN'S GONNA BE TAKING OVER
THE BUREAU OF HAD THE PLEASURE
OF WORKING WITH HER ON MY STAFF
AND I HAVE. A HIGHER EDUCATION
WORK THAT WE'VE BEEN DOING AND
I THINK TO BE A GREAT ADVOCATE
FOR STUDENT VOICES- AND
PROTECTING STUDENTS IN THE
BUREAU WHICH IS SHOULD BE IN MY
MIND THE SOLE FOCUS OF THE
BUREAU. I'VE RUN TWO BILLS-
THAT WOULD INCREASE IN STRENGTH
AND REGULATIONS OF THE PRIVATE
FOR PROFIT SECTOR AND BOTH
TIMES INCLUDING MY FIRST YEAR
WITH IT WHEN IT WAS QUITE A
SURPRISE TO ME. COLLEAGUES
WOULD SAY I SUPPORT WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO I THINK WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO IS
NECESSARY BUT I DON'T HAVE
FAITH THAT THE BUREAU CAN
HANDLE ADDITIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY- AND THAT WAS
INCREDIBLY DISCOURAGING TO
HEAR- AND WE'D WORK ON THE
POLICIES IN THE BILLS- AND
ALSO- WORK ON MY COLLEAGUES
CONFIDENCE TO GET THE VOTES
NECESSARY. WE WERE NOT
SUCCESSFUL THE FIRST TIME- WE
WERE SUCCESSFUL THE SECOND TIME
MAINLY BECAUSE WE MOVED A LOT
OF THE REGULATION TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE- AND
NOT TO THE BUREAU- AND SO I AND-
VERY INTERESTED. IN WHAT WE'RE
GONNA BE DOING THIS YEAR- TO.
REFORM THE BUREAU TO STRENGTHEN
THE PROTECTIONS FOR STUDENTS TO
MAKE SURE THAT. YOU HAVE THE
RESOURCES THAT YOU NEED AND
THAT THE SYSTEM IS SET UP
PROPERLY- BUT ALSO TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE RESPONSIBILITY- IS. IT
AND THE FOCUS IS WHERE IT
SHOULD BE. WHICH IS ON
PROTECTING STUDENTS. WHO IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY FAR TOO OFTEN. FIND
THEMSELVES BEING TAKEN
ADVANTAGE OF- BYE BYE PREDATORY
AND UNSCRUPULOUS- PRIVATE
PERFECT FOR PROFIT COLLEGES.
SOME ARE GREAT. AND SOME ARE
NOT- AND IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
HAVE THE DATA NECESSARY TO BE
ABLE TO EVALUATE WHICH ONES ARE
WHICH- AND THEN WITH THAT WE
HAVE THE REGULATIONS AND LAWS.
NECESSARY TO BE ABLE TO
PROPERLY REGULATE THOSE THAT
ARE MISBEHAVING. SO I WAS
ENCOURAGED TO SEE. ONE OF THE
BIGGER ISSUES THAT CAME UP A
LOT WAS THE NUMBER OF THE
BACKLOG OF COMPLAINTS- AND I
WAS ENCOURAGED TO SEE THAT THE
NUMBER OF COMPLAINTS. HAS
DECREASED BY ABOUT EIGHTY FIVE
PERCENT- BUT I WAS DISCOURAGED
TO SEE. THAT TWO THIRDS OF THE
COMPLAINTS. WERE CLOSE BECAUSE
THE COMPLAINT COULD NOT BE
SUBSTANTIATED. OR THE BUREAU
DETERMINED IT DID NOT HAVE
JURISDICTION- SO I GUESS ONE
QUESTION IS. WHAT'S THE
BREAKDOWN HOW MANY WORDS WERE
CLOSED BECAUSE THE COMPLAINT
COULD NOT BE SUBSTANTIATED. HOW
MANY WERE CLOSE BECAUSE- THE
BUREAU ARE DETERMINED THAT IT
DID NOT HAVE JURISDICTION- WHAT
WAS THE PROCESS. FOR COMING UP
WITH THOSE DETERMINATIONS. AND
DOES THE LEGISLATURE NEED TO
PROVIDE- EXPAND THE SCOPE. OF
THE BUREAU'S RESPONSIBILITIES.
TO ALLOW IT TO- INVESTIGATE
MORE THESE COMPLAINTSTHAT IT
DETERMINED THEY DON'T HAVE
JURISDICTION YOU DON'T HAVE
JURISDICTION OVER. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN- AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONTINUED FIGHTING
WITH ON YOUR LEGISLATION FOR
THIS ZERO. I WANT TO GO OVER
THE FAUCET THAT HAPPENED WITH
THE ENFORCEMENT- AND LOOKING AT
THOSE THINGS I DO HAVE- SOME OF
THAT THAT HE DID SO INFORMATION
I HAVE IS FROM THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN- PROFIT THAT IT WENT
THROUGH. AND CLOSING OUT THOSE
CASES- JUST REAL QUICKLY I CAN
GIVE YOU THE INFORMATION WE CAN
GET BACK TO YOU WITH
ADDITIONAL- DATA AS WELL. I'VE
BEEN LOOKING AT JEFF.
INDISPOSED CASES THAT CAME
FORWARD ABOUT 90% OF THEM WERE
ACTUALLY NONTRADITIONAL WHERE
THEY WERE CLOSED COOL OR- AND
WHEN THAT HAPPENED WE WOULD
REFER THE MATTER ON. CORRECT
THAT'S ONE THING WE WERE GOING
THROUGH THAT PROCESS AND JUST
TO GIVE ME A LITTLE BIT OF
BACKGROUND ON THE ACTUALLY HAD
IT YEP I CRACKED I DIDN'T KNOW
THAT THAT'S THE CASE IN FRONT
OF DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AFFAIRS PASSPORT. IN AND ARE IN
THE GOOD THAT WERE AT AT. LEVEL
OF INVESTIGATOR WHERE THEY BOTH
WENT IN AND EVALUATED THE- AND
WHAT THEY REALLY DID IT ALSO
WHILE THEY WERE DOING THEIR
EVALUATIONS THEY WERE ACTING
TRAINING BUT BASS. AND
ASSISTING THEM AND BEING ABLE
TO REVIEW PAPERS AND MAKE
CHANGES THAT THEY WENT FORWARD.
AND SO WHEN THEY WENT THROUGH
AND LOOKED AT THE CASE WITH THE
ULTIMATE LIKE THAT- INFORMATION
THAT THEY HAVE SO 90% OF THOSE
WORKLOADS. HOLD WORLD AND SO
THEY REFERRED A PATIENT OVER TO
STRICTER THEY COULD REACH OUT
TO STUDENTS AND ASSESS THEM ON
BECAUSE EVEN THOUGH THEY
COULDN'T TAKE ACTION AGAINST
THE SCHOOL THERE WERE STILL
STUDENTS THAT WERE HARMED AND
POTENTIALLY IN NEED OF FILING A
CLAIM SO THAT'S WHAT THEY GET.
THERE WERE ALSO THOSE THAT
WE'RE NOT PERFECT ABOUT 12% OF
THOSE THAT WERE REFERRED TO
ANOTHER AGENCY I'M AT BECAUSE
THEY'VE WORKED ON THIRD BEAT
THAT- OR THEY WERE EXACT- YOU
HE SAID FOR EXAMPLE- BOTH OF
WERE. INSUFFICIENT EVIDENCE
BOTH WERE 13% BOTH BOTH WORK
WELL BECAUSE. I'M WHILE THEY
MADE. THE ISSUE IS WORRIED THAT
WHEN THY WERE LOOKING AT THE
INFORMATION FROM UNIT THAT HAD
BEEN PROMOTED FROM ABOUT WHAT
OLD THOSE WHO ARE REQUIRED TO
KEEP INFORMATION FOR OVER FIVE
YEARS AND THEY HAD WAITED FOR
EITHER FILED A COMPLAINT
WORKING ON MY- OR IT'S BEEN
PENDING WITH. ZERO IF IT DIDN'T
MEET THAT CRITERIA WHAT. THE
TEAM DID IF THEY LOOKED AT OKAY
IF THEY'RE FROM OTHER AVENUES
THAT WE CAN'T TAKE ACTION RIGHT
NOW BE ON FACE ON THIS
COMPLAINT. WE FOR THE OVER FOR
A COMPLIANCE INSPECTION WE
ADDED TO THE INFORMATION THAT'S
GOING TO BE GIVEN- UP FOR
FUTURE REVIEW OF THAT WELL AS
BOTH INDIVIDUAL GO OUT. THE
OTHER THING THAT THEY DID SOME
OF THEM ARE CRIMINAL MATTERS
AND SO THEY REPORT THEM ON FOR
CRIMINAL ON ACTION AND THEN IF
THAT ENTITY TOOK ACTION TO GET
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE THAT THEY COULD
HAPPEN THEN IT WOULD BE
SOMETHING THAT THE FEAR WOULD
BE ABLE TO TAKE ACTION ON. AND
THE OTHER THING THAT THEY DID
SOME OF THAT STUDENT PAPERS
THAT WORK THEY WERE LOOKING OUT
BECAUSE LIKE YOU KNOW WHAT THIS
BECAUSE THEY WERE NOT THAT
LARGE NUMBER SOME OF THEM ONCE
THEY STARTED CRAWLING BUT
STUDENTS. THEY HAD ACTUALLY
ALREADY BEEN- BROUGHT MADE
WHOLE BASICALLY SO- THAT THEY
NEED WITH MATHEMATICS IN EITHER
THEIR PRACTICAL BEEN PROVIDED
OR THEY WERE WERE WE INVOLVED
KIND OF THINGS HAPPEN SO THAT
PRICING PLANT SO THEY WERE ABLE
TO BE CLOSE COMPLAINTS OF PAIN.
AND THEN THE LAST THING THAT
THEY GET IT IN A LOT OF THE
PAPERS THAT COMPLAINTS THAT
WERE PROVIDED THEY DIDN'T HAVE
ENOUGH INFORMATION TO BE LOOKED
AT- AND SO THEY THEY TRIED TO
CONTACT THE STUDENTS A LOT OF
THE STUDENTS WERE NOT AVAILABLE
THEY DID WHAT THEY COULD IN
LOOKING AT WILL RECORD BUT IF
THEY HAD IDENTIFIED A TEACHER
THAT WAS A PROBLEM OR THINGS
LIKE THAT. THEY LOOK AT THE
POLL RECORDS TO TRY TO IDENTIFY
THOSE INDIVIDUALS AND IF THEY
WEREN'T ABLE TO THEY DID HAVE
TO CLOSE THE CASE BECAUSE THERE
WAS NO OTHER ACTIVITY THAT
COULD BE TAKEN. SO I LOOKED AT
THAT I'VE I'VE MET WITH THE
GRANDMOTHER THEIR STAFF POPULAR
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE GONE
THROUGH THAT PROCESS- I AND I
DO BELIEVE THAT THEY- ARE.
APPROPRIATELY ANALYZE. AND
REVIEW THOSE PAPERS. AND THEN
THE INFORMATION THAT WE
PROVIDED THAT WE BELIEVE THAT
THERE'S A LOT THAT NEEDS TO BE
STRENGTHENED I'M BACK ONE OF
THEM WE BELIEVE THAT IT NEEDS
TO BE ALLOWED TO EVEN IF
THEY'RE THAT IT DOESN'T HAVE TO
HAVE. YOU KNOW I'M PRUDENT IT
HAD TO BE A POTENTIAL PERSON ON
LIKE OUR OTHER PORTLAND BUREAUS
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
CONSUMER AFFAIRS. AND THEN WE
ALSO HAVE A CASE IN THE BACK ON
PAPER OTHER AREAS WHERE WE NEED
PEOPLE THEY'RE GETTING APPROVED
OTHER PLACES WHERE WE NEED TO
HAVE- STRONGER LAWS AND
REGULATIONS AND SO THAT'S. WHY
WE REALLY WANT TO PARTNER WITH.
AND LOOKING AT WAYS THAT. THAT
THERE ARE- ENFORCEMENT AND I DO
WANNA- IT'S A GREAT IF HE-
ANYTHING TO ADD. WELCOME HE WAS-
IT VERY. WITH THAT THE PLOT.
ERECTOR YEAH THAT. DIDN'T HAS
BEEN ONE. WITH THE BUREAU FOR
SOME. AND JUST A LITTLE BIT.
AND IT'S EIGHT. THAT WE HAVE
FOR EXAMPLE- BIG. THAT WE WORK.
WITH HEAT OR CARBON PROPERTY.
OR WE WERE ABLE TO. DETERMINE
THAT STUDENTS WERE ACTUALLY A-
COURSES. OR AND WERE AT A- TO
SIMPLY STUDY YEAH I'M- THAT WE
WERE UNABLE TO. MOVE WITH.
EIGHTY AND BENEFIT OF ACTION.
DUE TO THE FACT OF NOT. AN
STUDENT COMING FORWARD CLAIMING
THAT THEY'VE BEEN HARMED AND
SOME OF THE STUDENTS WERE ABLE
TO HAPPEN EXAMINATIONS
THEREFORE THEY WERE MADE WHOLE
NAY RECEIVE THEIR LICENSES AND
THEN OTHER STUDENTS JUST WOULD
NOT COME FOR IT. AND BE
WITNESSES AS BEING PROVEN THAT
THEY ACTUALLY WERE HARMED BY
THE SCHOOL. THANK YOU. THANK
THANK YOU SO A QUICK FOLLOW UP
SO WHEN YOU MIGHT HAVE COVERED
THIS IN IN THE DIFFERENT
BREAKDOWNS BUT WHAT PERCENTAGE
OF THE CASES WERE DISMISSED AS
NON JURISDICTIONAL AND IN TOTAL.
AND HE DOES THAT OKAY. YES
SORRY THERE WERE TWO DIFFERENT
TYPE OF NON FICTIONAL ONE OF
FICTIONAL- WITH THEM BEING
CLOSE SCHOOL WORK I'M REFER TO
STRIP AND WITH MY PERCENT AND
THEN THE OTHER HUNDRED ALL THAT
WE TO LIKE ANOTHER AGENCY OR
THE ENTITY A DAMP OF THAT THAT
THAT COULDN'T TAKE HALF WITH
TWELVE. OF 1% OKAY. M. THEN IT
AND YOU WERE. THIS IS BIT IN
YOUR BUT WE WHAT'S FOR. DOES B.
P. P. DUE TO CONNECT ON BETWEEN.
POTENTIALLY NON JURISDICTION
COMPLAINTS AND ENFORCEMENT
CASES- THAT COMPLAINTS COULD
POTENTIALLY EVEN IF INDIRECTLY
INFORMED. I'M SORRY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MAN COULD YOU REPEAT
THAT QUESTION- OF COURSE SO
IT'S A WHAT WHAT DOES THE
BUREAU DUE TO CONNECT THE DOTS
BETWEEN. POTENTIALLY NON
JURISDICTIONAL COMPLAINTS AND
ENFORCEMENT CASES THAT THOSE
COMPLAINTS COULD POTENTIALLY-
EVEN IF INDIRECTLY INFORM.
LEAVE THAT. YEAH SO- ME. THE
ENFORCEMENT UNANIMOUS. LOOK AT
EACH COMPLAINT OF THE CONTENT
INDIVIDUALLY AND WE LOOK AT IT
SEE IF IT IN ANY TYPE OF
VIOLATION OF ANY OF OUR LAWS OR
REGULATIONS AND WE CAN LOOK AT
IT AND MORE IN DEPTH NOT TO FOR
FACE VALUE AND THEN IT DOES GO
TO MY MANAGER AND THE MANAGER
TAKES A DOUBLE LOOK AT IT TO
ENSURE THAT- THAT IT REALLY IS.
NONFERROUS SO WE HAVE KIND OF A
TWO. PROCESS WHAT WE LOOK AT IT
IT'S AN INTAKE OF IT AND WE
ALSO LOOK AT IT AT THE CLOSE
RATHER TO JUST ENSURE THAT.
GOSH OF ADDITIONALLY I WOULD
LIKE TO ADD THAT THERE MAY BE
TIMES THAT- ONCE WE START THE
INVESTIGATION THAT WE FIND THAT
IT'S NONTRADITIONAL. OKAY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FALL. BUT THANK
YOU TEARS. I WOULD LIKE TO
FOCUS I GUESS ON THE ELEPHANT
IN THE ROOM WHICH IS- THE FEES
AND THE OPERATIONAL COSTS OF
THE- OF THE BPP- IN MY
UNDERSTANDING AND CERTAINLY AND
THE CENTRAL VALLEY- THESE
INSTITUTES ON A NUMBER OF THESE
INSTITUTIONS PROVIDE- CRITICAL
PATHWAYS. FOR STUDENTS IN THE
MEDICAL FIELD IN IN INTO
NURSING- AND- THE SCHOOLS
CERTAINLY AS WELL AS EVERYONE
HAS BEEN STRUGGLING TO
PERSEVERE TO THIS PANDEMIC.
AND- NO DURING THIS TIME OF
UNCERTAINTY- I WOULD THINK THAT
WE WOULD WANT TO PROVIDE SOME
STABILITY TO THE SCHOOLS SO CAN
YOU KIND OF GO WALK ME THROUGH
THE- DEADLINE SET OR THE
PERSPECTIVE OF. WHY THESE FEE
INCREASES ARE SO SUBSTANTIAL-
WHY THEY'RE NECESSARY-
ESPECIALLY SINCE IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT- FEES WERE
INCREASED IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
AND TWENTY EIGHTEEN- AS A WERE
HAVING INSTITUTIONS ARE
LOOKING- POSSIBLY PAYING
UPWARDS TO NINE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS- YOU KNOW TO.
TO TRY TO PROVIDE SINCE THE
MEDICATION- AND THEN COULD YOU
ALSO ADDRESS HOW THE FEE
INCREASE PROPOSAL- COINCIDES
WITH THE INFORMATION THE
INSTITUTIONAL CAPS THAT
CURRENTLY EXISTS IN LAW. YES
YOU'RE RIGHT THIS IS THE
ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM I WOULD
AGREE WITH YOU- BECAUSE WITH
WITHOUT THE SOLVENCY OF THAT
YEAR- WE WILL NOT BE ABLE TO DO
A LOT OF THE WORK THAT WE HAVE
STARTED ALREADY AND SO ON I
JUST I WANT TO WALK YOU THROUGH
THIS IT MAY TAKE ME A MINUTE TO
GET THROUGH IT SO I APOLOGIZE
IN ADVANCE FOR THE LEAD
RESPONSE- FIRST OF. IT IN
REGARDS TO THE FIRE FEE
INCREASE- THAT DID OCCUR- I
MEAN LET AND THE BACK UP JUST A
LITTLE BIT MARC FIRST OF ALL
THIS IS VERY DIFFERENT ALL OF
THE OTHER PAYROLL QUICK EXAMPLE
WITHIN THE OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS
AND THEIR PAY STRUCTURE IS
INCREDIBLY COMPLEX- THEY HAVE
INDIVIDUAL APPLICATION FEES AND
THEY HAVE REMOTE BE IF WHEN
INDIVIDUALS COME FORWARD THAT
ARE DIFFERENT THAN- THE NORMAL
READING ALL BECAUSE THEY FALL
OUT INSPECTIONS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT- AND THEN THEY HAVE THE
ANNUAL FEE THAT IS BASICALLY-
MADE FUN A PERCENTAGE OF THE
ANNUAL REVENUE RECEIVED FROM
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS- ATTENDING
THOSE. INSTITUTIONS I'M SO THAT.
HE IN ANOTHER. IF THEY UPON HOW
IT WILL. WILL LARGELY WEEK-
THAT IT NOT LIKE ANY OTHER.
BORDER WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
CAN AFFAIRS THIS IS A SLUSH-
THE TARGET THAT WORD WHAT. I AM
IF IT NOT ALL THAT PREDICTABLE
THOUGH WE DO TO PRINT. AND
REGARDING THE EVEN SEVEN EIGHT
WE HAD. THAT BUT THE AMOUNT OF.
THAT WE THOUGHT GOING TO HAPPEN.
AND BASED ON SCHOOL. BECAUSE IT
HAPPENED GOTTEN IS. BY THE
LOCAL. AND ANNUAL FEE IS PER OF
OUR- FACE ON. CLOSURES AND
BASED ON OTHER AGAINST HAPPEN.
ON WE WORK ABLE TO THAT.
REVENUES WE THOUGHT IN ONE OF
YEAR I THINK BY A LITTLE BIT
OVER NOW. DOLLAR SO THE REVENUE
AND OF ITSELF- BUT- WAY IT IT
GATHERED IS. AN AND IF YOU
COULD SAID DEFINITELY TO LOOK
AT- SO THE ONLY REVENUE FOR.
THAT'S KIND OF WHERE WE NEED.
ON THAT SIDE ON THE- SIDE HAD
BEEN SEVERAL. THAT HAVE CHANGED
WITH THIS BUREAU OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS- I DO WANT TO
STAY THAT YOU. THOUGH IN THAT
THE SENATE EIGHTEEN ALL THAT WE-
ONE THE- ONLY AMOUNT WHAT
ANNUAL FEE- I BELIEVE IN MAKING
OTHER. CELL THERE WITH THAT
BACK IN ALL OF THE OTHER PIECE
BACK THOUSAND ELEVEN. WHEN THEY
WERE. WERE INCREASE I'M- SO
IT'S A WORKING AGO THAT ALL OF
THE- HAVE BEEN LOOKED AT AND I
CAN. FOR INCREASE. THAT PREMIUM
SAID A LOT OF THINGS HAPPENED
WITH. OVER THE LAST YEARS BUT
ACTUALLY WITH AND LAST. THIS
CALL LAST EVERY WITH THE ZERO.
THE FIRST THING THAT ALL WE'RE
GOOD GIRLS I UNDER CA ALL OF
THE STATE IS IT. UNDER THE SAME.
THE WE HAVE AND THAT THAT THE
LAST SEVERAL. I HAVE BEEN SET
SEVERAL. EMPLOYEES PACKAGE THAT
HAVE FOR. SO FOR EXAMPLE IN
OFFICE. NAY OR A ASSOCIATE AND-
BACKING TO THOUSAND THIRTY.
WHAT THEY WERE MAKING FROM
COULD. IT. THEY ALL INCREASE-
SIGNIFICANTLY THAT 30% AND
OTHER- OTHER TYPES OF- THE
STAFF IT'S EVEN A LARGER
PERCENTAGE SO. THAT'S ONE THING
WE HAVE TO RECOGNIZE. THE OTHER
THING WITH IT. IT'S NANCY
TWELVE THIRTEEN TIME FRAME AS
THEY STARTED IN TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN THEY ACTUALLY INCREASE
THEIR STAFF BY SIGNIFICANTLY SO
THEY HAD. I'M FORTY. SEVEN NEW
STAFF IS SIMPLE LAST NIGHT THAT
THERE WERE TWENTY SEVEN NAY
STAFF INVOLVED. IN EVERY TWENTY
EIGHT WHAT. ARE NOW ON SALE
STAFF SEVENTEEN OF THEM WINNING
TWO ONE FOURTH SO THAT'S- THAT
THEY PROVIDE. COULD IMPROVED.
ON IN ADDITION WITH THE- A
DIFFERENT UP OLD. THAT IT ADDED
ANOTHER STEP ELEVEN AND IF YOU
THE WITH PC THAT WENT. ALL
THOSE INCREASE SIGNAL. THERE'S
ALSO THE COST AND WHEN YOU HAD
INCREASES AND THAT IT DOESN'T
INTO THE BUREAU STAFF. IN THAT
THE ALL OF THE STATE. SO DEEPLY
AND THINK WHY PROGRAM IN FOR.
THAT WOULD A SIGNIFICANT. FOR
THEM AS WELL AS THE- GENERAL.
HAS GONE UP AGAIN ALL. BACK TO
THE- FEELINGS THAT. WELL ALL OF
THOSE THINGS THAT IMPACTED THIS
YEAR. AND THEN THE LAST THING
IMPACT WITH THEM REALLY IT'S
IMPLEMENTATION OF THE NEW I
KEEP. THAT WAS ANOTHER THING
THAT IN THAT. ALL OF THAT WE IN
A SIGNIFICANT INCREASE IN THE
AMOUNT OF THEIR X. AND LOT OF
IT IS OF THEIR- WHAT HAVE THEY
DONE BABY WILL AT. THAT ARE IN
WHAT WE THEIR. AND SOME OF
THOSE THINGS IN. THAT THEY'D
LOOK AT IT THEY SAY AND ACT HAD
TO LOOK AT BECAUSE THE COLD IN
MY- WHAT ARE. COSTS WHERE CAN
FIND THE- WITH. WITH ME IN A-
AND WITH THE POPE SOUTH HAVE
THE WORD GOING MORE ONLINE
THEREFORE WE CAN FIND. AND ALL
LOOKING OTHER. THE OTHER THING
AND IT IT WON'T HAPPEN QUICKLY
BECAUSE THEY JUST RECENTLY BUT
IN THE FUTURE LET'S LOOK AT
BOTH WE- WORK BUT- NOBODY
CLAPPED BECAUSE NOW WITH
HOMEWORK I THINK WE CAN CUT
DOWN ON OUR OUR PHYSICAL. TO
WHERE WE CAN ACTUALLY HAVE A
LOWER RENT ALL OF THESE THINGS
ARE WHAT THEY'RE LOOKING AT.
THINGS THAT ARE UNDER THEIR
CONTROL THE SALARIES AND OTHER
ENTITIES INCREASING FAT IT'S
NOT AND SO THAT'S WHY IT FITS
POINT THERE IS THAT NEEDED BE
INCREASE TO BASIC CONTINUE TO
FALL BEFORE THAT. SO I COULD
APPLY UP I GUESS I HEARING.
THERE'S MANY THINGS THAT ARE.
ADAM AN OUT OF THE CAN. OF
THESE AND SEE- AND I'M OF THE
BUREAU THE BUT THE BUREAU
SEEING THE NEED TO FOR MORE
REVENUES OF THE RAISING FEES
BUT THEN. WHAT THE INSTITUTIONS
CAN CONTROL IS VERY LIMITED.
AND SO I GUESS YOU KNOW. UP I
CAN SEE LIKE A FOR EXAMPLE I
HAVE HEARD THAT A- NOW BRANDON
MAX BRAND TO BE CAMPUS CAMPUS
V. IN TWENTY SIXTEEN WITH A
THOUSAND DOLLARS. AND THEN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN IT BECAME
SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS AND THEN
THE OTHER THIS PROPOSAL IT'S
LIKE A HUNDRED FIFTEEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS. SO AND I GUESS WHAT I
DIDN'T HEAR I GUESS IS IT HOW
IS IT THAT YOU DO YOU. ARE YOU.
TO THE IN. CAT THAT CURRENTLY
EXIST AMERICA IS AN INSTANCE
GONNA PAY. ONE POINT ONE
MILLION DOLLARS TO TRY TO STAY
FOR. MAKE THE STATE THAT TO BE
ABLE TO OPERATE. WE HAVE MADE
SOME OF CAP MISREPORTING AYE
AYE HAVE HER TALK TO BUT THE
CHAIN IN THAT THE- BUT WHAT WE
GET IS THE RECOMMENDED. THAT IN-
THE- STUDY THOUGH WORK OR
RECOMMENDATION THAT OUT THIRD
IN. ACTUALLY LOOK AT AND
PROVIDE. AND SO THAT THE DATA
SOMETHING THEY- WOULD MAKE IN
AND LOOKED AT THAT MONEY THAT
IS NEEDED HE SAID ZERO
TOLERANCE. ON THAT'S WHAT THEY
WERE PROPOSED AN SELF WE HELP
YOU. CAN WE'RE AT RAY FELLOW
ARMS THAT IS THAT WE'RE LOOKING
AT NOT IT'S READY BREK ATTY
BECAUSE THAT- CAP ON ON THAT I
KNOW YOU POOR ANNUAL
INFORMATION. WELL I THINK A TO
GO AHEAD THE EMIR OF GOING. I
THANK- FIFTEEN KERN CAP IS
SIXTY THOUSAND DOLLARS OR AT
EACH. LOCATION WHETHER IT BE
THE MAIN THE PRICE AND THEN THE-
PREVIOUSLY THERE WERE THOUSAND
WOULD FOR EACH. WITH EIGHT. AT
EMAIL. WHAT THEY DID THEN IN
THE- FEE INCREASES WAY TREATED
EACH FOR HAS AS ITS OWN
REVENUES. AND HIT THE MINIMUM
AND CAP ON THAT SPECIFIC BRANCH.
AND WE GOT LOT FOR TO
PARTNERING WHEN THE LEGISLATORS
AND BOND AND OUT OF OUR FEES-
APPROACH TO FIFTY. SO I AM I
THAT CARE FOR I MEAN I- I'M SO
CONCERNED A THESE BEING.
ESPECIALLY I MEAN AS A AS A
LEAD TO THERE WERE THE CENTER
VALLEY- YOU NO MATTER ACCESS
EDUCATE ACCESS VERY VERY. AND
I'LL AT LEAST INSTEAD PROVIDE
THAT PATH AS I SAY EARLIER
INDECENCY ALSO OTHER TO SAID TO
BE IRAN TO THE B. THAT THE- THE
B. T. THERE WERE NO. YOU KNOW
SHOULD LOOK AT THIS IN A BAD.
BECAUSE WERE WERE WERE LATER
FIELD FEET OF BEING. AND-
THAT'S GOING TO HAVE A LOT OF
AND I CONTACT AND I WOULD JUST
SAY. NOW THE- OF YOU KNOW THAT
PERCENT AS OF YOUR REVENUE OF
YOU OPERATING IS TO IS REVENUE-
I'M NOT SURE RACES ANNABLE. AND
I THINK THAT- I'M SEEING A
RECIPE FOR DISASTER WE HAVE.
THE LEGISLATURE WHO IS. BLARING
ON MORE. ON THIS ON THIS. WE
HAVE AN ANTIQUATED COMPUTER
SYSTEM THAT NEEDS TO BE.
ADDRESSED AND WE HAVE NOW FEWER
SCHOOLS THAT ARE NOW GOING TO
SEE A MASSIVE FEE INCREASE-
THAT'S JUST NOT A SUSTAINABLE
MODEL. AND I JUST ENCOURAGE
THEM YOU KNOW THE COMMITTEES
INVOLVED IN ALL OF US TO LOOK
AT THAT VERY. VERY CLOSELY-
BECAUSE WHEN WE TALK ABOUT
SUSTAINABILITY ONLY TALK ABOUT.
HIS INSTITUTIONS WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO LOOK AT THAT THANKS
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
A SIMILAR FONG IT JUST DIDN'T
TO THAT POINT- TO. AADHAR DCA
DIRECTOR ON PAGE EIGHTEEN. OF
THE SUNSET REVIEW PAPER LIST
THE CATEGORIES OF THE CURRENT
pINCREASE. IN FACT I HAD TO GO
TO ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE STAFF
BECAUSE I THOUGHT THE MATH WAS
INCORRECT- BUT FOR EXAMPLE- ON
THAT'S FROMTHE TOP. FIVE DOWN
ON FOR THE APPLICATION FOR
APPROVAL TO OPERATE BY MEANS OF
ACCREDITATION. THE CURRENT FEE
IS SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS
THE NEW FEE IS TEN THOUSAND
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS. A ONE
THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED AND 9%
INCREASE. AGAIN I THOUGHT THAT
THAT NUMBER WAS WAS INCORRECT
BUT I WAS TOLD THAT THAT'S-
THAT IT WAS FACTUAL OR IT TO
SEE BELOW THAT A SEVEN HUNDRED
AND 17% INCREASE. OR EVEN LOWER
THE FIVE HUNDRED AND 11%
INCREASE AS I THINK YOU YOU'D
BE HEARING BECAUSE WE HAVE THE
PRIVILEGE OF YOUR TIME AS DCA
DIRECTOR YOU'RE HEARING NOT
ONLY FOR BP. BUT ALSO FOR A
NUMBER OF OTHER ENTITIES THAT
ARE. THE REAL CONCERN ABOUT
THESE FEE INCREASES ESPECIALLY
TIMES OF THE COVERT PANDEMIC
THAT WE FEEL LIKE THAT MIGHT BE
SOME- THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THESE ISSUES. THAT
MIGHT BE A LITTLE TONE DEAF- SO
WE WELCOME IN AND SOME OF THE
OTHER REMARKS AS WELL TOO BUT
WE'LL GO WITH AND THEN TO THE
NEXT- PERSON WHICH IS ASSEMBLY
WOMAN VOLUNTEERS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR. SO MY QUESTION
IS- AROUND EXEMPTIONS FOR
RELIGIOUS INSTITUTIONS AND- THE
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE B. PP.
THAT WE'D CHANGE LANGUAGE TO
SPECIAL SPECIFIED THAT MORE OF
AND THEN FIFTY PERCENT- IS
FOCUSED ON RELIGIOUS THE
RELIGIOUS PRINCIPLE OF THAT
RELIGIOUS ORGANIZATION. CAN YOU
EXPLAIN OR CLARIFY AS TO WHY
YOU MADE THE RECOMMENDATION
AND- GIVE ANY SPECIFIC
EXAMPLES. ON THAT LED TO THAT
WHY. YES I'M ACTUALLY GOING TO
HAVE MEANT THREE FATTY- BAKER
THAT THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING
THANK YOU. A HAS BEAN AND MANY.
APPLICATIONS COMING THROUGH FOR
A VERIFICATION OF RELIGIOUS
EXEMPTION WHERE THE ACTUAL
PROGRAMS AREN'T CLEARLY
OUTLINED AS BEING RELIGIOUS IN
NATURE AND MORE- EITHER
BUSINESS. A LOT OF- MBAS ERICA
SAYS THAT WE'VE- IS THEREFORE
EIGHT. WE'RE LOOKING AT
SOMETHING THAT WILL PROVIDE AS
MORE GUIDANCE ON AND ENSURING
THAT THERE TRULY MEETING THE
LEGISLATORS INTENT WHAT THE
EXEMPTION. AND AGAIN MY CONCERN
HERE IS ONE IS SAID THERE'S
ALREADY OVERSIGHT FROM THE
BUREAU AS YOU WOULD YOU AND DO
YOU CURRENTLY NOT APPROVE OR DO
YOU HAVE TO APPROVED BECAUSE OF
EXISTING LANGUAGE. SO WE
CURRENTLY APPROVED. ADDING TO
THE EXISTING LANGUAGE IT'S JUST
NOT- HERE TO FEEL THAT IT COULD
BE A CLEARER EXEMPTION THAT
WOULD- PROVIDE A COLLAPSE OF
THE DISCRETIONARY IN THAT
SITUATION. AND IS IT GOING TO
REQUIRE ANY ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR YOU TO- AND FORCE
THIS. YEAH WE DO NOT WE DON'T
REQUIRE ANY ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR R&D- AND
PROCESSING THESE APPLICATIONS
AND IF WE AND THEN IT MAY
ACTUALLY WEAPONS SOME OF THE
COMPLEXITY THAT WE DO HAVE WITH
IT WHEN WE'RE UNABLE TO VERIFY
AN EXEMPTION AND- HAVING TO. GO
BACK AND FORTH EITHER THROUGH
THE ADMINISTRATIVE LAW PROCESS
OR WHAT HAVE YOU. SO WOULD YOU
ANTICIPATE APPEALS OR IS THERE
AN EXISTING WILL THERE BE. IS
THERE AN EXISTING APPEAL
PROCESS OR WILL THERE BE
OPPORTUNITY APPEAL. THERE IS AN
EXISTING ECHO PROCESS AND WE
BELIEVE THAT IF THE LAW IS
CLEAR THAT WE WOULD BE LEFT THE
FIELD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SENATOR GLAZER
FOLLOWED BY CHAIRMAN DID. THANK
YOU I'D TO THE CHAIRS IN THE
COMMITTEES FOR SOMEONE IN THIS
YEAR AND CAN CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES. OKAY TERRIFIC- IN TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN- THIS E. AT
THE ASSEMBLY PUT FORWARD A
COMPREHENSIVE PACKAGE OF BILLS-
PRIVATE POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION THAT WERE HEARD IN
THE SENATE BUSINESS PROFESSIONS
COMMITTEE. I THAT WE PASSED A
NUMBER OF THOSE BILLS. A NUMBER
OF BILLS ARE ALSO AMENDED WITH
THE UNDERSTANDING THAT WE-
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE THIS SUNSET
REVIEW THAT IS TAKING PLACE NOW
A YEAR. LATER THAT IT WAS
EXPECTED AND THAT SOME OF THE
MORE DEEPER ISSUES THAT THOSE
THAT THAT LEGISLATION RAISED
WOULD BE BEST HANDLED THROUGH
THAT- SUNSET REVIEW. SO I WANT
TO THANK AT YOUR LOW INSURE
ROCK. AFTER THEIR WILLINGNESS
TO DIG MUCH MORE DEEPLY INTO
THIS ZERO- AND THAT THE
PERFORMANCE OF THE CHALLENGES
THAT THEY HAVE FACED- IT'S VERY
MUCH APPRECIATED. BUT I WANT TO
LET IT KNOWLEDGE AT LEAST ONE
OF THE CORE ISSUES THAT WAS
RAISED. DURING THAT THAT THAT
THOSE HEARINGS AND THAT'S THE
ISSUE OF COST THE COST TO
STUDENTS- AND OF VALUE TO
STUDENTS. AND THOUGH THE
CONCERN THAT THAT WASN'T
MATCHING UP IN THE WAY THAT IT
SHOULD. AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT. MANY OF THE PROGRAMS
PROVIDED BY THESE PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS AND BY THE WAY
MANY OF THEM ARE OPERATING WITH
HIGH INTEGRITY AND
EFFECTIVENESS. BUT MANY OF THE
PROGRAMS PROVIDED BY THESE
PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS COULD BE
PROVIDED BY PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS
RIGHT NOW. WE HAVE OVER A
HUNDRED AND FORTY. COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES IN OUR STATE. WITH
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF
PROGRAMS AND HUNDREDS OF DEGREE
OPPORTUNITIES. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S STILL NOT
SERVING THE GREATER CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY. SO I WANTED TO USE
THIS OPPORTUNITY WITH CHAIR
MEDINA AND SURE LEYVA PRESENT
AS WELL TO HIGHLIGHT THE FACT
THAT WE SHOULD BE LOOKING MORE
DEEPLY INTO THESE GAPS THAT ARE
OUT THERE THAT THE PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS ARE- BILLING. AND
SOME WITH MANY MANY WONDERFUL
PROGRAMS BUT WE COULD LOWER THE
COST AND INCREASE THE VALUE
QUOTIENT. OF OUR PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS WERE ENGAGED. I AM
FILLING SOME OF THESE GAPS THAT
THE STUDENTS CLEARLY WANT OUR
ECONOMY NEEDS SO I WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT THAT THANK YOU FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY GIVE YOU. MY
COMMENTS AND TO SHARE THAT
PERSPECTIVE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH CENTER GLAZER. CHAIRMAN
TINA. THANK YOU I HAD SEVERAL
QUESTIONS- IN IN THE AREA OF.
DISTANCE EDUCATION OUR FIRST
QUESTION HOW CAN THE BUREAU
INSURE THAT CALIFORNIA'S
STUDENTS ARE PROTECTED WHEN
THEY'RE ATTENDING INSTITUTIONS
THAT MAY NOT MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS FOR A PHYSICAL
PRESENCE THAT WOULD TRIGGER
GIRLS OVERSIGHT. AND I AM AN
ADMINISTRATOR FREDDIE TO ANSWER
THAT QUESTION THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CURRENTLY REQUIRES OUT OF
STATE INSTITUTIONS ARE OFFERING
SECONDARY EDUCATION THROUGH
DISTANCE EDUCATION TO
CALIFORNIA'S DIDN'T. TO
REGISTER WITH THE BUREAU AND
WITH THAT REGISTRATION THEY
HAVE TO HAVE AN APPROVAL AND
ARE HOME STATE AND BE
ACCREDITED BY AN ACCREDITING
BODY THAT'S RECOGNIZED BY THE
U. S. FUNDED EDUCATION. ZERO
ENSURE THAT THE OTHER STATE
ENTITIES AND YOUR CREDITORS ARE
HOLDING THOSE INSTITUTIONS TO
THEIR STANDARDS AND IF A
COMPLAINT IS RECEIVED WE
INVESTIGATED AND WORK WITH
THOSE ENTITIES TO FOLLOW UP
INTO AND HELP IT DIDN'T COME TO
A RESOLUTION. AND I JUST LIKE
TO ADD ON THE FACT THAT I
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS AN AREA AS
WE REQUESTED THIS YEAR THAT
WE'RE HAPPY TO DISCUSS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AN INDETERMINATE
THERE'S ANY- THING NEEDED TO
STRENGTHEN THAT PROCESS AS WELL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU THAT ANSWER-
RECENTLY I WAS- MADE AWARE. OF
ARIZONA STATE UNIVERSITY. THAT
HAS A CENTER OF PHYSICAL
CENTER. IN DOWNTOWN LA- WHAT
ROLE DOES THE BUREAU HAVE IN
REGULATING PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS
LIKE ARIZONA STATE THAT HAVE A
PHYSICAL PRESENCE. IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND ARE OFFERING
CLASSES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WITH A PHYSICAL
PRESENCE. AT THE ATLANTA THAT
MEASURE BUT IF YOU HAVE
ANYTHING TO ADD TO WEEK WE'RE
AWARE THAT SOME OF THOSE OUT OF
STATE UNIVERSITY THAT WE ARE
PLANNING OR HAVE RECENTLY
OPENED- PHYSICAL CAMPUSES IN
CALIFORNIA- BUT BECAUSE BPP IAN
REGULATIONS THAT THEY REGULATE
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS WE DO NOT BELIEVE
THAT THE ISSUE CURRENTLY FALLS
UNDER THE JURISDICTION- HOWEVER
AGAIN TO FIND THAT MY EARLIER
COMMENT WE REALLY LOOK FORWARD
TO ENCOURAGING- ENGAGING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE. AND THE
ADMINISTRATION AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS ON THAT ISSUE AND
A CREDIT YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO
ADD AND THAT BASICALLY COVERED
FANTASY HE. SAID ZERO IS. I
MEAN BY THAT. TO RISE. PRIVATE
SECONDARY EDUCATIONAL.
THEREFORE WE DON'T HAVE THE
ANSWER TO WRITE. PUBLIC
INSTITUTION. THANK YOU N. AND
YOUR YOUR IS GOING IN THE
DIRECTION OF MY NEXT COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS SO BECAUSE WE HAVE
INSTITUTIONS LIKE- FORMER
BRIDGE POINT. RUNNING THE
UNIVERSITY OF ARIZONA GLOBAL
CAMPUS OR KAPLAN BECOMING
PURDUE GLOBAL. AND SO THIS
SEEMS TO BE A TREND. OF THE.
NOT FOR PROFIT- HIGHER LEARNING
INSTITUTIONS ACTING LIKE FOR
PROFIT- HIGHER LEARNING. AND SO
AND SO- AGAIN IS THIS A CONCERN
OF THE BUREAU AND- IS THIS A
CONCERN. YES DEFINITELY IT IS
SOMETHING THAT WE WANT TO LOOK
AT AND AGAIN- WE BELIEVE THAT
WOULD PROBABLY POTENTIALLY BE
NEEDED LEGISLATION IN THE
FUTURE SO AGAIN THAT'S WHERE WE
REALLY WANT TO PARTNER WITH YOU
AND LOOK AT THAT. PROCESS SO
THERE ARE A- POTENTIAL AT
LOOPHOLES IN THE LAW THE
PERHAPS NEED TO BE ADDRESSED.
YES YES PEOPLE LEAVE THAT IT'S
DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT WE
NEED TO LOOK INTO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. CHILUBA
THANK YOU CHAIR OKAY THANK YOU
TO MY COLLEAGUES TO ANSWER
AFTER MOST OF MY QUESTIONS
WHICH IS GREAT WE'RE ALL ON THE
SAME PAGE I DO HAVE OF.
ADDITIONAL QUESTION WHEN IT
COMES TO ACCREDITATION. AND I
JUST LOST IT. AND SORRY IF THE
MINIMUM OPERATING STANDARDS I
WANT TO ASK ABOUT OUR THE
CRITERIA ESTABLISHED IN THE ACT
THAT ALLOWED INSTITUTION TO
BECOME A LICENSED STRONG ENOUGH
TO PROTECT STUDENTS AND PROMOTE
STUDENT SUCCESS SO ARE THE
STANDARD STRONG ENOUGH. SO I'LL
START THAT AN ANSWER AND THEN I
YOU MAKE AT THE OPTIMIST OR
FREDDIE TO ADD ANYTHING HE HAS
ADDED WELL. AS YOU CAN SEE IN
OUR BACK PAPER- WE DO HAVE
ITEMS THAT WE BELIEVE COULD
HELP THE BUREAU- IN ITS MINIMUM
OPERATING STANDARDS AND SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT ARE IN
THAT ACTUAL- THE SUGGESTION.
AND THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS WE
COVERED IN THAT SO WE
DEFINITELY BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
THE ROOM WHERE AT PLACE WHERE
THERE IS ROOM FOR IMPROVEMENT
AND ROOM FOR ACCEPTANCE FROM
THE LEGISLATURE AND I CAN HAVE
THAT FOR FREDDIE BECAUSE THAT
SPECIFICALLY. AS TO WHAT THOSE
ARE. THANK YOU DIRECT. AND ZERO
RECOMMEND THAT WE HAVE THAT
WERE PROVIDED THE AUTHORITY TO
STRENGTHEN OUR MINIMUM
OPERATING STANDARDS AROUND AND
EAT THE CHARGES THAT THE
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS ARE
CHARGING THE STUDENTS IN THE
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE IS IT IN
LINE WITH THE CURRENT CHARGES
AND OTHER- OTHER INSTITUTIONS I
JUST DIDN'T PAINT TO MATCH HER.
IN IN ONE AREA. ADDITIONALLY-
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS THAT ENROLL
INTO A PROGRAM IS APPROPRIATE
IS THERE ENOUGH EQUIPMENT IS
THERE ARE ENOUGH TEACHERS AND
SO FORTH TO ENSURE THAT THOSE
STUDENTS ARE GONNA GET THE
OUTCOME THAT THEY'RE PAYING
FOR. AND THE OTHER SECTION IS
THAT THE EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS
ARE BEING EVALUATED FOR THEIR
EFFECTIVENESS. WE I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE READER AND
THE PROGRAM IS SUFFICIENT- YOU
KNOW WE HAVE THE SCHOOL
DEPARTMENT FACT SHEET THAT THE
SCHOOLS ARE REQUIRED TO PROVIDE
YET THERE'S NO STANDARDS FOR
THOSE DIFFERENT TACK SHEET-
COMPLETION RATE GRADUATION RATE-
PLACEMENT RATE OR- EXAMINATION
RIGHT. SO THOSE ARE DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT WE'RE THAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT THAT WOULD HELP THAT
STRENGTHENS THE EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAM. ANY BUT I THOUGHT
REGULATIONS THAT MAY BE NEEDED
TO MAKE CHANGES IN THE
APARTMENT AND OPERATE YEAH WELL.
THANK YOU WELL ANY WE CAN DO
BECAUSE ALL THE THINGS THAT
WERE MENTIONED I THINK-
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT MAKING
SURE STUDENTS HAVE ACCESS WHEN
THEY ENROLL IN THE HAVE ALL OF
THE- UNNECESSARY ITEMS TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. AND I JUST WANTED
TO ALSO COMMENT ON SENATOR
GLAZERS COMMENTS- I DO AGREE
THAT MANY OF OUR INSTITUTIONS
ESPECIALLY OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES COULD FILL SOME OF THE
GAPS THAT WE SEE WITH OUR POST
PRIVATE SECONDARY INSTITUTIONS-
MYSELF SHARE MEDINA HAVE DONE A
LOT OF WORK ON OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. AND I THINK THAT WE
CAN DO EVEN MORE WORK TO MAKE
SURE THAT THAT HAPPENS. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CHAIR LEYVA. WELL
THEN GO TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON FOLLOWED BY CHAIR ROTH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOUR GROUP
THIS QUESTION MAY HAVE ALREADY
BEEN ASKED OR ANSWERED ALREADY
BUT PLEASE INDULGE ME. DO YOU
THINK THAT THE DO YOU FEEL THAT
THE FEE INCREASE- IS- NEEDED TO
KEEP THE BUREAU SOLVENT. YEAH
DEFINITELY ED AT THAT POINT IN
TIME- YEAH THAT'S NOT LIKE
OTHER A STRUCTURAL IMBALANCE.
BETWEEN ART. AND BUDGET YOU
KNOW I'M JUST PART OF IT HERE
ARE. WE ARE ACTUALLY TALKING
THE EIGHT THANK FOURTEEN LONG
IN ORDER STATE CRICKET HERE I
AWHILE BACK BONUS HELPFUL WHAT
IT DOES DO THAT DRIVES UP A CAR.
OF THAT THE INCREASE FOR THAT
YEAR I'M- WE OPPOSED COULD IT
THEIR LAP YEAR WITH THE- SENT
THAT WE PROCESS AND TWENTY-
THAT COULD BE PUT IT DOWN ON
THE AND SO HAD TO THAT THAT. IF
YOU'RE IN THAT LOW WAS NOT. I'M
IN ORDER FOR THE- WE FALL AND
THAT YEAR AND IT WILL COULD HE
AND I. YEARS IF DO NOT I'M FINE
I'M DISCUSSION WHERE WE CAN
HAVE WITH YOU WITH THAT A- OF A
THEY CALL TO WEAR WE CAN. A
FULL TO THE PROBLEM. WELL ONE
OF THE DIFFERENT DO THERE'S NO
QUESTION MISTER CHAIRMAN- HAVE
ANY ALL LINE I'M SO. LOS ACCRUE.
DURING THE- I DON'T MISTER
FREDDIE WILL HAVE I DON'T I'M
NOT WE MAY TO GET BACK TO YOU
ON THAT QUESTION. WE THANK YOU
HAVE A YEAH I WOULD DEFINITELY
HAVE TO GET BACK ON THAT-
QUESTION I DON'T KNOW WITH ANY
OPETH MY HEAD THAT HAVE
ACTUALLY LOST THEIR CREDIT
ASIAN- I BELIEVE WE'VE HAD A
COUPLE. AND INSTITUTIONS THAT
WERE NOT DISCLOSED EDUCATION
O'CLOCK THEIR CREDIT ASIAN
DURING THE TIME. THAT WE HAVE
MICHAEL HAD BELIEVE IN AND YOU
CAN CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG BUT
I BELIEVE WE HAD PEOPLE THAT
HAVE ACTUALLY CLOSED SO- DURING
THE PANDEMIC LIKE PERMANENTLY
CLOSED OTHERS HUNDRED RECALLS
THAT EVERYONE CAN'T FIFTY
SCHOOL BOARD NINE PEOPLE THE
HAD TO CLOSE. I THINK IN PART
IT WAS BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC
BUT THEN ALSO SOME OF THE WILL
BUT MENTIONS THAT THEY
ACTUALLY- WE'RE WE'RE LOOKING
AT CLOSING ANYWAY THEY HAD
OTHER ISSUES COME UP AND THAT'S
THE KIND OF WHAT THAT THE
LAUGH- HE SAID THAT THE PUZZLE
THAT PUTS THEM OVER THE EDGE.
WHEN SOME OF THOSE SCHOOLS A
DECIDED TO CLOSE FOR OTHER
REASONS OTHER THAN A PANDEMIC-
HOW HAVE THOSE HAVE THOSE
STUDENTS BEEN. HOW THOSE
STUDENTS HOW'S THAT BEING
HANDLED WITH THE WHAT IT COMES
DOWN TO THOSE SCHOOLS CLOSING
AND THOSE STUDENTS. THAT MAY
HAVE LOANS THERE AND OR-
CLASSES BECAUSE I CAN REMEMBER.
THAT WE HAD ONE UNIVERSITY THAT
CLOSED DOWN AND STUDENTS WERE
ADVERSELY- AFFECTED AND IN THE
LEGISLATURE HAD TO STEP IN TO
TRY TO ASSIST IN- CREDITS IN
CLASSES THE WHOLE NINE YARDS
SO- DO YOU HAVE ANY. RESPONSE
TO THAT QUESTION. WE DEFINITELY
NOT HAVE HANDLING THAT OFF YOU
MISTER BELL BIRTHDAY OUR-
TARGET. FOCAL FOR THIS IN. AND
THEY HAVE- BEEN A SHINING. WITH
THE BUREAU WITH WHAT HAVE DONE
FUNDING THEY CAN. THANK YOU
DIRECTOR KERR PRIOR THANK YOU
FOR QUESTION- YES WE- TAKING
VERY- APPROACH TO. OUR AVERAGE
EFFORTS AROUND. NOT SCHOOL
CLOSURES PROJECT DURIG THE
TIME- OF THE KOBE CRISIS. A
STARTING AT THE- NOT MANY
SCHOOL HAVE I KNOW. THE OF
THEIR TEMPORARY. CLOSURE WITHIN
YOU CAN. TO HOPEFULLY REOPEN A
POST CAL THE- WE AT THAT TIME
EACH OF. AND CON THIS. AT
ROSTER. AND MAKE IT CAN I. WITH
THE SCHOOL AND OUR METHOD TO
GETTING PROACTIVELY. IN THE-
THAT HI OF THE CLOSED. WILL
SCHOOL MAY THAT CLOSE.
PERMANENTLY SO TAKEN A C<c.cyan>G</c>
OF. REGARDING OF WHERE THEY
HAVE- INDICATED TO THAT THAT
INFORMATION TO. I'M THE PLANET
OR NOT. ONCE WE BECOME A OF.
REGARD OF WHERE THEY MAY. COMES
FROM WHETHER IT BE. THE SCHOOL
THAT FELL OR- US DEPARTMENT
VEGGIE. OR WHOMEVER- WE ARE
JUMPING WE- GET- STUDENT ROCK.
MAKE WITH THE STUDENT- IF YOU
WERE. IN A VIRTUAL IN MY- IF
THAT. THEN WE WILL PARTNER WITH
THE US DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
AND THEIR OUTREACH TEAM TO SORT
OF APPROPRIATE TO STUDENTS WHAT
THEIR OPTIONS ARE. OFTEN OTHER
SCHOOLS ARE INVOLVED AS WELL AT
THE OFFICE AND WE'RE PROGRAM IN
OUR OFFERINGS EITHER DO A TEACH
OUT OR TAKE THOSE STUDENTS YOU
NEED TO TRANSFER- WE SERVE AS
SORT OF A LIAISON. YOU NAVIGATE
THAT AS WELL- OR IN THE WORST
CASE SCENARIO YOU KNOW WHERE
THEY WERE OUT OF POCKET- AND
ECONOMIC BASED ON OUT OF POCKET
PAYMENTS TO THE SCHOOL AND WE
CONNECT THEM WITH THE STUDENT
TUITION RECOVERY FUND. AND LOOK
FOR THE BALLET- SO YES WE'RE
DEFINITELY HELP YOU THE FUTURE
AND IF I CAN'T TAKE A MINUTE TO
GO BACK TO. GET ALLOW ME TO
SPEAK TO SENATOR GLAZERS
COMMENTS ABOUT- TO COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND OTHER OPTIONS FOR
STUDENTS AS WELL. THE
CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE COLLEGES-
ARE ALSO A STATUTORILY NAMES
PARTNER FOR- SORRY- AND SO I
CREATE A BATHROOM AMONGST OTHER
PARTNERS THAT WERE IDENTIFIED
IN OUR STATUTE AND SO WE
CLOSELY CONNECT WITH THEM OUR
OUTREACH EFFORTS. AND WE'RE
MEETING WITH PROSPECTIVE
STUDENTS.PART OF OUR CHARGE IF
YOU- AT THE STUDENTS WITH ALL
OPTIONS ARE RELATED TO WHAT
THEY ARE- EDUCATIONAL
VOCATIONAL GOALS ARE- INCLUDING
OUR PUBLIC OP OPTION IN
NONPROFIT EXAM SCHOOLS ETCETERA
AND WE GO THROUGH IN DETAIL.
WITH OUR CONTENT TO SORT OF
TALK ABOUT THOSE OPTIONS AS
WELL AS VALID OPTION FELT. ALL
THE MATH MESSAGING. THROUGH OUR
OUTREACH EFFORTS AS WELL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH J. FOLLOWED BY
SOME WOMEN GRAYSON. THANK YOU-
JERRY YOU KNOW I'M SORT OF NEW
TO THIS- BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS CAN AND THE BUREAU
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION.
OBVIOUSLY FROM WHAT I'VE READ
AND WHAT I'VE BEEN HEARING YOUR
MISSION IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT
TO STUDENTS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- BUT GIVEN
THE VARIOUS ISSUES THAT WERE
IDENTIFIED IN OUR- BACKGROUND
PAPER I'M I'M JUST CURIOUS WHAT
WHAT DO YOU CONSIDER TO BE
YOUR- CORE MISSION. AS A BUREAU.
THE COURT MENTIONED THAT THIS
IT IT PROTECTION BY THE WAY
I'VE BEEN HAVING TROUBLE
HEARING YOU MA'AM AND I'M
PROBABLY THE OLDEST GUY IN THIS
ROOM BY FAR BY FAR AND- IT'S
OBVIOUSLY A TESTAMENT TO MY AGE
AND THE QUALITY OF MY YEARS.
WHICH OBVIOUSLY IS FOR BUT IF
YOU WOULD SPEAK SLOWER AND A
LITTLE LOUDER. THAT WOULD HELP
ME. I AM SORRY ABOUT THAT
SENATOR RAP. ON IT IS STUDENT
PROTECTION THAT IS THE CORE
MISSION OF THE BUREAU FOR
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION.
OKAY WELL YOU KNOW IN LOOKING
THROUGH THE MATERIAL IT'S
PRETTY CLEAR TO ME THAT THE-
SPAN OF CONTROL OF THE BUREAU
IS PRETTY WIDE. AND GIVEN THE
FACT THAT YOU COVER EVERYTHING
FROM FOUR YEAR DEGREE GRANTING
INSTITUTIONS TO. OF SCHOOLS AND
PROGRAMS THAT AWARD LICENSES
AND CERTIFICATES AT THE END OF
THE COURSE OR A SERIES OF
COURSES- IS THIS. THE WAY WE
STRUCTURED THE BUREAU- ONE
STILL FEASIBLE. AND TO IF I CAN
ASK YOU QUESTIONS AT THE SAME
TIME HOW DO YOU PRIORITIZE YOUR
EFFORTS GIVING GIVEN THE FACT
THAT THERE ARE TREMENDOUS
DIFFERENCES IN THE PROGRAMS
THAT YOU OVERSEE. HI I'M GONNA
START OUT HERE AND I BELIEVE
I'M GONNA KICK THE TOP TWO BIT
BUT PROBABLY BOTH METRIC AND-
IT'S ABOUT FORTY PER RESPONSE.
FIRST OF ALL IS THAT FEASIBLE-
AND AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW IN
THAT THE BACKGROUND PAPER AND
THE INFORMATION THAT'S BEEN
PROVIDED WHEN WE DID THAT THE
STUDY ONE THING THAT WE LOOKED
AT IT. IS NOT FEASIBLE TRULY A
TO CONTINUE THE WAY WE'RE DOING
IN THE WAY WE HAVE TO EXPORT
THAT THE GIRL STRUCTURE- AND SO
THAT'S WHY I'M ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE'RE THINKING
ABOUT DEPENDING ON WHAT OUR
DISCUSSION'S THOUGH I'M THIS
YEAR IS. POTENTIALLY LOOKING AT
AN ECONOMIST COME IN AND
IDENTIFY IF THAT'S THE
APPROPRIATE WAY TO BE-
PERFORMING BUT SERVICES THAT
THE BUREAU AND CHARGING
INDIVIDUALS I'M TO BE ABLE TO
OBTAIN REVENUE ALSO. THAT
THAT'S IN RESPONSE TO YOUR
QUESTION FOR FEASIBILITY BUT
ONE THING I WANTED THAT
DISCONTENT SUSPECT AT DESKTOP
BEFORE I PASS IT OFF TO- LIZA
AND MR ALREADY AT THAT TRULY IN
LOOKING AT THAT. THEY ARE VERY
DIFFERENT THAN OTHER BOROUGHS
AND BOARD WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS ON THE WAY
THEY'RE STRUCTURED. AND
EVERYTHING PRETTY MUCH ABOUT
THEM IS VERY DIFFERENT BECAUSE
AGAIN WHEN OF THAT BORDER
BUREAU WHOSE LICENSING AN
INDIVIDUAL WHEN THEY'RE LOOKING
AT HOW DO I PROTECT THE
CONSUMERS ARE LOOKING AT THE
INDIVIDUAL COMING AND
IDENTIFYING HAS THIS INDIVIDUAL
MET ALL OF THE REQUIREMENTS-
AND SO THAT'S WHAT HEY'RE
LOOKING AT. BETTER BASICALLY
CHECKING THE BOX MAKING SURE
THAT IT MEETS EACH PIECE OF
WATER EACH PIECE OF WATER
REGULATION TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT INDIVIDUAL CAN PRACTICE
AND IN IT. LET ME GET THIS
INDIVIDUAL LICENSES QUICKLY AS
POSSIBLE ON THE BACK IN WHEN WE
TAKE ACTION AGAINST THOSE
INDIVIDUALS YEAH LET ME TRY TO
IF THIS INDIVIDUAL IS IT IS
OFTEN SAID THAT PUBLIC THEN
LET'S STOP AND- PRACTICING. BUT
IF THEY CAN CONTINUE. THEN
LET'S CONTINUE TO BRING THEM ON
A DATE COULD REHABILITATE THAT
INDIVIDUAL LICENSE PLATE. AT
THE WHERE THE BUREAU IS. THEY
NEED TO WIN THE BIG. WHEN
THEY'RE LOOKING AT THE- AS THEY
ARE. BY OF WELL AS REQUIREMENTS
THAT THEY REALLY NEED HELP. UP
BROADLY THE IS SOMETHING THAT
JUST. COME TO OUR- A KIND OF
LOOK AT THE OUTSIDE BOX. WE TO
BE ABLE TO. GET THOSE IN THE
BILL SCHOOL. TO ONLY CHECK THE
BOX BUT IT. THE PHILIPPINES THE
END OF SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO
START GOING. ON OUR NEEDING
THEIR CLIMATE IN THERE'S ONE
THING THE BILL FOR THE SCHOOL.
AND HAD EDUCATION COUNCIL. THAT
REVIEW THAT AND THOSE IN THE-
THEY DO ADD AN AND NOW. OF
REALLY TO. VERY ON THAT TO THAT-
PART- ELEMENT IN MISSION OF THE
PROGRAM ON THE IN. MAYBE THIS
IS SOMETHING WE NEED LOOK AT
DISCUSS WITH YOU TO. GENERAL'S
TO WEIGH WE CAN ACT I GUESS. ON
AND MAKE IT UP I THAT WE TAKING
SCHOOL AND IF THEY- COME IN TO
COME. THAT WE NEED TO. IT STOP
THOSE CALLS GOOD FROM BEING
ABLE TO PRACTICE AND TO- HELP
THAT. AND WITH THE AS FAR
PRODUCT. IN A PATH THAT
OPTIMISTS FREDDIE ON BECAUSE I
KNOW THEY PRIOR. AND ALL WANTED
THE OTHER PRIORITIZATION IS IT
HELPING INDIVIDUALS GET THOSE
STRIP CLAIMS FILED. WITH BOTH
OUR- IT JUST SEEMS TO ME
THERE'S A TRUE. DE WHEN YOU
TAKING A LOOK AT A- SCHOOL THAT
IS A FOUR YEAR HIGHER READ.
OPERATION FOR EXAMPLE THAT
AWARDS BACCALAUREATE DEGREES.
TAKING A LOOK AT THAT AYE
OPERATION AND THEN TAKING A
LOOK AT THE SCHOOL THAT TRAINS
PLUMBERS IN ISSUES OF PLUMBER
CERTIFICATE OR AN HVAC
CERTIFICATE SOMETHING FOR
SOMEONE ELSE. AND IF THE CORE
MISSION IS IN IN ESSENCE
CONSUMER PROTECTION IN THIS
CASE STUDENT CONSUMER
PROTECTION THEN YOU HAVE A CORE
GROUP OF ISSUES. THAT PERHAPS
YOU SHOULD OBVIOUSLY SHOULD BE
LOOKING AT BECAUSE SOMEONE
NEEDS TO. BUT MAYBE THAT
DOESN'T EXTEND TO THE QUALITY
OF THE FACULTY OR SOME OF THOSE
OTHER ISSUES THAT YOU MENTIONED
EARLY EARLIER IN YOUR
PRESENTATION SO WHAT WHAT DO
YOU SAY TO THAT. THAT'S WHAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT IN TERMS OF
SPAN OF CONTROL AND BREADTH OF
ISSUES. AND WHERE DO YOU FOCUS
IN A IN A STATE THAT'S
BUDGETARY EARLY CHALLENGED AND
YOU DON'T EVEN TAP THE GENERAL
FUND. AT THE LAB HAS SET UP AND
EVERYBODY TALK ABOUT THAT.
STATION THANK YOU DOES THE GIRL
HAD AND AS DIRECTOR CHRIS MEYER
IT IS FOLKS YOU EDUCATION
CONSULTANTS WHO ARE DIVERSE IN
THEIR EDUCATION AND THEIR
EXPERIENCE IN WORKING- IN
REVIEWING AND THE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF PROGRAMS THE DEGREE
PROGRAM FIRST WITH THE
VOCATIONAL PROGRAM AND- AND
ALSO WORKING WITH OTHER BOARDS
AND BUREAUS WHO ARE LICENSING
ENTITIES TO REVIEW AND APPROVE
CURRICULUM AS WELL SO WE DON'T
DIFFERENTIATE PRIORITIZING.
WHICH WHAT SCHOOL WE LOOK AT
FIRST WE LOOK AT THEM ALL
EQUALLY BUT UNDER DIFFERENT
REQUIREMENTS AS A YOUR BODY YOU
KNOW POINTED OUT THAT IS A
REQUIREMENT 4 DEGREES PROGRAM
IS DEFINITELY DIFFERENT THAN A
REQUIREMENT FOR VOCATIONAL
PROGRAM- IT YOUR MAIN
PRIORITIES ARE DEFINITELY
REGARDING THE STILL DIDN'T
PROTECTIONS LOWER LOOKING AT
ENFORCEMENT COMPLIANCE
INSPECTIONS AND SO FORTH WE
HAVE PRIORITIES AND SET UP TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
THE SCHOOLS YOU KNOW WILL DO AN
INSPECTION ON SCHOOLS THAT-
HAVE RECEIVED MORE COMPLAINTS-
THOUGH THEY'LL BE A HIGHER
PRIORITY FOR US. FIRST IS THE
SCHOOL HAVE RECEIVED ANY.
COMPLAINT AS AN EXAMPLE. THANK
PATHFINDER SPOT MISTER GABORONE.
THANK YOU FOR YEP IN OUR IN A
WORLD- OF YOU KNOW WORKING THE
SCHOOL ON THE CLOTHES BY AS
WELL AS SKIPPER- AS IT RELATES
TO ECONOMIC RESTITUTION AT THE
TIME OF CLOSURE THERE'S QUITE A
VARIANCE AS WELL DEPEND ON THE
TYPE OF SCHOOL- THAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH YOU KNOW LIKE YOU
MENTIONED THE LARGE- MULTI
CAMPUS. ACCREDITED DEGREE
GRANTING INSTITUTION WITH TITLE
FOR FUNDING- IT IS A QUITE A
DIFFERENT UNDERTAKING THEN OUT
A SMALL CLOSURE OF SIX PEOPLE
IN A SOLE PROPRIETORSHIP WHILE
OFFERING OF A VERY NARROW
PROGRAM- BUT BUT IN EACH CASE.
WE TAKE THE THAT THE IMPACT ON
THAT EQUALLY SERIOUSLY- THAT
THE PRIORITIZATION IS REALLY
ABOUT JUST GETTING OUT TO WITH
MANY STUDENTS WHO ARE WHO ARE
AFFECTED. BY THAT CLOSER AND
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE AND THEN
JUST- WE BUILD CAPACITY AND
RESOURCES TO BE ABLE TO DEPLOY
A- THE RESOURCES THAT ARE
NECESSARY DEPENDING ON THAT
VARIANTS OF THE TYPE OF SCHOOL
IS CLOSING BUT THAT FROM A
PRIORITY PATIENT STANDPOINT
IT'S- YOU KNOW WHEN SCHOOL
CLOSURES HAPPEN AS EARLY AS
POSSIBLE GET OUT THERE MAKE
CONNECTION WITH THE STUDENT
WITH THE SCHOOL TRIED TO GET
THEIR ACADEMIC AND FINANCIAL
RECORDS AS SOON AS POSSIBLE.
BECAUSE EVERY EVERY MINUTE
COUNTS. ONE OF TELL YOU. QUITE
AMAZED THAT- GIVEN THE IN. OF
THIS BUT- ISSUE PARTICULARLY IN
THE AREA OF CONSUMER CONSUMER
STUDENT CONSUMER PROTECTION-
THAT THIS OPERATION- IS NOT
FUNDED IN WHOLE OR AT LEAST IN
PART OUT OF THE GENERAL FUND.
AND SO MY NEXT QUESTION SORT OF
PIGGY BACKS ON A QUESTION AND I
BELIEVE MR FONG AS- HAVING TO
DO WITH THE- THE SUSTAINABILITY
OF THIS OPERATION IN AND
LOOKING THROUGH THE BACKGROUND
PAPERS YOU KNOW LIKE. TWO NOTED
WHAT APPEARED TO BE STAGGERING
FEE INCREASES AND I THINK IT
WAS TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN. AS
OPPOSED TO THE DATES THAT WERE
EARLIER REFERENCED- STRUCTURAL
DEFICITS DEFICITS CONTINUE
DESPITE THOSE. RATHER
SIGNIFICANT TO FEE INCREASES
ACROSS THE BOARD. OUR
BACKGROUND MATERIAL REFLECTS.
DESPITE THE STRUCTURAL DEFICIT
THAT THE BUREAU. IS REQUESTING
A ADDITIONAL AUTHORITY
INCLUDING FRANKLY WHAT APPEARS
TO ME TO BE AUTHORITY TO MOVE
INTO THE ACCREDITING AREA WHERE
ACCREDITING BODIES. CURRENTLY
PERFORM CERTAIN FUNCTIONS
INCLUDING QUALITY OF FACULTY
AND SOME OF THE OTHER. OTHER
OTHER ASPECTS OF EDUCATION AT
VARIOUS LEVELS- WHICH OBVIOUSLY
PRESUMABLY WILL REQUIRE EVEN
MORE WORK ON THE PART OF THE
BUREAU- AND ITS PERSONNEL IN AN
AREA IN AN ERA OF- FEE
INCREASES AND STRUCTURAL
DEFICITS. AND GIVEN THE- WHAT
APPEARS TO BE SHRINKING BODY OF
SCHOOLS. IN THIS SPACE PAYING
THESE FEES I GUESS MY BASIC
QUESTION IS. IN YOUR VIEW. IS
THIS FINANCIAL MODEL.
SUSTAINABLE I THINK THAT'S WHAT
MR FONG WAS TRYING TO GET OUT
HERE. AND IT'S CERTAINLY WHAT
I'M TRYING TO GET AT OR SHOULD
WE BE LOOKING AT A DIFFERENT
FINANCIAL MODEL FOR THIS BUREAU
IF IN FACT. YOUR VISION. THE
ADMINISTRATION'S VISION IS A
MUCH MORE EXPANSIVE ROLE IN
THIS PRIVATE POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION SPACE. BEYOND WHAT AT
WHAT SOME WOULD ARGUE IS A CORE
STUDENT CONSUMER PROTECTION
STUDENT LOANS DEFAULTS. SCHOOL
CLOSURES AND THE LIKE. SENATOR
ROB I AGREE I MEAN I THINK
THAT'S EXACTLY THE REASON WHY
WE NEED AN ECONOMIST TO COME IN
AND LOOK AT THE FUNCTION AND
THE ROLE AT THE BUREAU AS WELL
AS WHAT IS CURRENTLY THE
REVENUE STREAM- FOR THE FOR THE
BUREAU- WE'RE WE'RE WE REALLY
THINK THAT IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
SOMEONE COME IN THAT THEY
PROVIDE THAT INFORMATION THAT
THEY TAKE KIND OF A DEEP DIVE
INTO THE INFORMATION. OUT THE
PIANO HOW IT HOW IT WORKS AND
THEN REPORT BACK AND LET US
KNOW IF THERE'S SOMETHING THAT
WE NEED TO CHANGE THE WAY WORK
WELL THE WAY WERE GATHERING
REVENUE AND THE WAY THAT WERE
FUNCTIONING AT. THE WHOLE
PURPOSE BEHIND POTENTIALLY
BRINGING IN THAT COMMENT TO
LOOK AT THAT ISSUE. INCLUDING
FUTURE PRODUCTION- I WORK AND
HOW WE WOULD BE LOOKING AT THAT
AS WELL AS THE WEAK I GET WEAK
WE WILL LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING WITH YOU IN THAT
ENDEAVOR RIGHT AND- HOPE HOPE
THAT WE CAN COME TO SOME
RESOLUTION FOR IT THAT IT COULD
BE THAT REALLY ENDS- THAT THE
PROTECTED IN. OKAY WHAT WAS THE
LAST ONE FINAL. I KNOW IN THE
BACKGROUND- I DON'T HAVE PAGE.
BY THERE WAS A CAR. AND ALSO IN
THE CONVERSATIONS IN THE
LETTERS THAT WERE SUBMITTED TO
THIS COMMITTEE AND TO THE
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE.
CONVERSATION ABOUT. MAKING SURE
THAT THE LICENSES OR-
CERTIFICATIONS ARE ISSUED AT
THE END OF THE WHATEVER THE
PROGRAM IS THAT YOU'RE- YOU'RE
LOOKING AT. BUT MY QUESTION
GOES TO THIS SO IN YOUR REVIEW
OF THE SCHOOLS AND IN. ENSURING
THAT THESE SCHOOLS THAT ARE
WITHIN YOUR PURVIEW. OF DELIVER
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS AS
PROMISED TO STUDENTS- DOES THIS
BUREAU. MEASURE WHETHER
STUDENTS WHO ARE TRAINED IN WHO
COMPLETE THESE EDUCATIONAL
PROGRAMS. NOT ONLY RECEIVE A
LICENSE OR CERTIFICATE AS
PROMISED. BUT THAT THE STUDENTS
ACTUALLY RECEIVE JOBS IN THE
AREAS FOR WHICH THEY PAID TO BE
TRAINED. AND IF NOT I'M IF NOT
WHY NOT. OKAY I MEAN NOT OVER
TO METRIC READY FOR THEM
FREETHOUGHT. THANK YOU THE
SCHOOLS ARE REQUIRED TO USE THE
NET THE WHAT WE CALL THE SCHOOL
DEPARTMENT FACT SHEET AND FAQ
AND THEY ARE REQUIRED TO
PROVIDE INFORMATION ON AND THEN
THE PERSON TO START THE PROGRAM
AND THE NUMBERS TO GRADUATE IF
THERE'S ONE CONCERN ABOUT THE
NUMBER OF STUDENTS TO TAKE THE
EXAM AND THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
WHO PASSED THE EXAM OR FAIL THE
EXAM AND. THEN AND THEN IT'S-
PROGRAM IS A JOB AS A PRO THAT.
TO LEAVE TO AT. A JOB IN SOME
WAY THEN THEY HAVE TO REPORT.
AND HOW MANY OF THOSE STUDENTS
THAT DID GRADUATE. DID GET A
JOB IN THAT FIELD AND WHAT
THEIR INCOME IS SO ALL OF THAT
INFORMATION IS REPORTED THROUGH
OUR- ANNUAL REPORT INFORMATION
AND IT WILL PROMPT FACT SHEETS
AND THE PUBLIC ABOUT IT ALL OF
THE STUDENTS- AND- SO WE
RECEIVE THAT INFORMATION
HOWEVER THERE ARE NO. STANDARDS
THE SCHOOLS HAVE TO MEET SO IN.
A ONLY SHOW THAT PERCENT
GRADUATE RATE THERE ISN'T A-
THAT MEN ARE STANDARD FOR THAT
HOWEVER IT DOES TRIGGER AS TO
GO AND LOOK AT THAT PROGRAM AND
FIND OUT WHAT IS GOING ON IT
YOU KNOW IS THERE SOMETHING
WRONG WITH THIS PROGRAM THAT
THESE STUDENTS ARE COMPLETING
OUR GRADUATING FORM SO IT EVEN
THOUGH THERE'S NOT A STANDARD
WE DO USE IT AS A TOOL TO LOOK
DEEPER AND AN INVESTIGATION
STAND IN OUR- INSPECTIONS. WELL
I'M NOT I'M NOT TOTALLY SURE
THAT COMPLETELY ANSWERED MY
QUESTION YOU KNOW ONE OF THE
ISSUES OF STUDENT CONSUMER
PROTECTION I ASSUME THAT DROVE
THE CREATION OF THIS ENTITY WAS
THE FACT THAT STUDENTS ARE
PAYING A LOT OF MONEY IN THESE
PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS FOR
WHATEVER AND NOT NECESSARILY
RECEIVING THE BENEFIT THAT THEY
THOUGHT THEY WERE PROMISED.
WHICH I ASSUME IN THE CASE OF
JUST ABOUT EVERY STUDENT WHO'S
PAYMENT WHO PAYS MONEY FOR
EDUCATION IS A GOOD PAYING JOB
IN THE FIELD THAT THEY SEEK THE
TRAINING IN SO. GIVEN THAT. WHY
ARE WE- INSISTING. THAT SCHOOLS
TO DELIVER US INFORMATION ON
HOW MANY OF THE STUDENTS TO
GRADUATE AND OBTAIN A LICENSE
OR CERTIFICATION. GETS A JOB IN
THE FIELD FOR WHICH THEY WERE
TRAINED BY THAT SCHOOL. THAT IS
PART OF THE PART BACKSHEET
REQUIREMENT THAT THEY DO REPORT
AND JOB PLACEMENT AND ERNIE. IN
THE FIELD ATHLETE TRAINING.
THAT'S ACROSS THE BOARD. YES
SIR DO WE HAVE THOSE STATISTICS
BECAUSE I DON'T SEE THEM IN MY
BACKGROUND MATERIAL. WE CAN GET
THOSE FOR YOU THEY ARE PART AS
THE- SCHOOL PARTS ACTUALLY SEMI
ANNUAL REPORTS REPORTED ON IT
THAT THE SCHOOL'S REPORT TO US
YOUR EARLY SO WE CAN DEFINITELY
GET YOU THAT INFORMATION. DO
YOU HAPPEN AND IT IS NOT
AVAILABLE. DO YOU HAPPEN TO
REQUIRE THE AVERAGE PERCENTAGE
RATE ACROSS THE BOARD FOR THE
PRIVATE SCHOOLS THAT YOU
OVERSEE. NO SIR WE DO NOT HAVE
THAT LEGISLATIVE AUTHORITY TO
REQUIRE THAT THEY NEED A
PERCENTAGE RATE. NOW I'M
CONFUSED I THOUGHT YOU
INDICATED TO ME THAT YOU DO
RECEIVE INFORMATION FROM THE
SCHOOLS THAT TIES GRADUATION IN
A PARTICULAR FIELD WITH JOB
ACQUISITION IN THAT FIELD IS
THAT CORRECT. YES SIR WE DO
REQUIRE THAT THEY SUBMIT THAT
INFORMATION TO US NAY PROVIDED
TO IT HOWEVER THERE IS NO. AND
LEGISLATION THAT REQUIRES THAT
THEY NEED A SPECIFIC PERCENTAGE
IN ANY OF THOSE CATEGORIES AND
THAT THAT WOULD RESULT IN ANY
TYPE OF. ACTION FROM THE BUREAU
WELL I UNDERSTAND THAT I'M JUST
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT'S THE
AVERAGE PERCENTAGE OF GRADUATES
WHO OBTAIN JOBS IN THE FIELD
FOR WHICH THEY WERE TRAINED. IN
THE TOTAL. POOL OF SCHOOLS THAT
YOU REVIEW. OH SORRY I
MISUNDERSTOOD YOU AND WE CAN
DEFINITELY GET YOU THAT
INFORMATION I DON'T HAVE IT
READILY AVAILABLE TO ME RIGHT
THIS MOMENT OKAY IT IS ON OUR
WEBSITE. OKAY I THINK THAT
WOULD BE FINE BECAUSE I THINK
THAT YOU SHOULD BE USING THAT
AS A MEASURE OF YOUR SUCCESS AS
WELL. BECAUSE OF STUDENTS PAY
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
TO GET A DEGREE OR A
CERTIFICATE OR A LICENSE AND
THEY CAN'T GET A JOB IN THAT
FIELD AND WHAT'S THE VALUE OF
THE PROGRAM. SO I WOULD BE I'M
GONNA BE VERY INTERESTED IN
TAKING A LOOK AT THAT. AND
TRYING TO. YOU KNOW COMPARE
APPLES TO APPLES WHEN IT COMES
TO THIS. I THINK I'VE SPOKEN
ENOUGH I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
AND YOUR PRESENTATION THANK YOU
WHAT YOU'RE A LITTLE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH A SIMILAR GRAYSON
FOLLOWED BY SOME A MEMBER CHOI.
THANK YOU JERROLD THANK YOU
CARILLO AND ALSO TO EACH OF THE
OTHER CHAIRS AS WELL AND TO MY
COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE ALREADY ASK
QUESTIONS THAT I SHARE AND
CONCERNS- THAT I SURE AS WELL I
BELIEVE THAT- WE WE'VE COME TO
THE SUBJECT A COUPLE TIMES
ALREADY I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE IT
JUST THAT ONE NEXT STEP FURTHER
AGAIN GOING BACK TO FEES. AND
THE- I GUESS FOR LACK OF BETTER
WORDS THE STAGGERING INCREASE-
THAT IS BEING PROPOSED ON THE
FEES- IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THE BUREAU BELIEVES THAT
THE PROPOSED FEE INCREASES ARE
ACTUALLY NOT ENOUGH TO KEEP THE
BRUTAL SOLVENT LONG TERM IF
THAT IS ACTUALLY THE CASE- THEM
HOW LONG DO. DO WE PROJECT THAT
OTHER MURAL WILL BE BACK TO
ACTUALLY ASK FOR AN INCREASE
ONCE AGAIN IN ORDER TO KEEP THE
BUREAU SOLVE. ACTUALLY IN THAT
THE BACKGROUND PAPER IN IN THAT
THE STUDY ARE PROPELLED THAT
CAN IT THAT CAN CONTINUE- BEING
SOLVENT FOR QUITE AWHILE AND I
DON'T. HAVE THE ACTUAL NUMBER
HELP OUR HELP IN THE FUTURE
THAT WOULD TAKE THEM IF THEY
WERE ALL IMPLEMENTED AFTER BUT
THEY DID NOT BE STUDIES- BUT I
WILL. GET THAT INFORMATION AND
GET BACK TO YOU BUT IT WOULD
CARRY THAT FOR QUITE A FEW
HERE. UPDATE ON ALLEN THAT BUT
THAT THAT LEVEL THAT HAVE BEEN
IDENTIFIED. BY THAT THE STUDY.
THANK YOU. ALSO BUT I GET THAT
IN THERE ALSO PAYING BACK THAT
EIGHT MILLION DOLLAR LOAN WELL
AND THEN GO BEING A EIGHT FIND
OR AND FIFTY SO IT COULD CARRY
THAT INTO THE THAT WHAT THAT
WELL. IN THE END ABOUT THE
STUDY. THANK I ALSO MY OF THE
CONCERN OF SENATE CHAIR OF
BUSINESS PROFESSION WHEN IT TO
THE MISSION AND THE HUGE BROAD
SWATH. OF IN WHICH YOU YOU A
WHAT YOU'RE REALLY TO APPLY.
AND IF THAT WAS THE CASE AND
STAYING HYPER FOCUSED ON THAT
MISSION HOW THAT MAY AFFECT-
THE BUDGET AND WHAT
EXPENDITURES WOULD RESULT FROM
THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI. THANK YOU
CHAIR. THROW YOUR QUESTION AND
ANSWERS LOS A PRIOR SESSIONS
SORRY ARE HAVE A- MOST OF THE
ANSWERED THE HOWEVER I'M
FOLLOWING UP I WAS SENATOR ROTH
AND- ASSEMBLY MEMBER OPERATIONS
QUESTIONS SO ARE YOUR CORE
MISSION OF A PPV- P. IS SO
CONSUMER PROTECTION AND- FOR
YOU TO- YOUR ORGANIZATION IS OF
A VERY. STRANGE A WORD THE I
READ THE- IN THE MILITARY THAT
THE ANOMALY OF ALL CONSUMER
AFFAIRS A DIVISION OF THE
BUREAU IS- AND THE YOUR
AGENCIES ARE TOTALLY RELYING
UPON ALL THE FEES SO THAT THE
YOU WHILE COLLECTING. AND NOT
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY YOU ARE LOW
OR REVENUE YOU ARE TRYING TO-
STAYS ARE ONE AND BY RAISING
THE FEES. ARE HAVE YOU THOUGHT
ABOUT- IF YOU DO REYES- FEES.
ARE SOME OF THIS- A POST
SECONDARY AGE IS- SO WE- ARE
WITH THE X. A HAVE A STRUGGLE
TO STAY AFLOAT DURING THE PHONE
AND THAT MAKE ETCETERA. AND
THEN ALSO A BEGINNING- THE U.
S. STAGE SCORES. ARE AND- THEY
NOT US. OUR LOT OF FOR THE
HOSPITAL THE FEES ARE NOT MADE.
UNDER EXISTING SCHOOLS UP TO
FOR THE CLOTHES SO WARM TO A
BRAND NEW ONE SO MAY NOT. BE
ABLE TO YOU KNOW OPEN IT UP. IF
THAT HAPPENS- DAN THOSE
CHILDREN'S- THE DOCTOR MISSION
TO YOUR TO PUT THEM- IF THOSE
SCORES SO DO CLOSER A WILL WHEN
THEY GO THEY WILL BECOME THE
VICTIM. SO I WONDER IF THERE'S
ARE AS- AS TO SENATOR RON
FORMATION DEVICE SO. OF FEE-
STRUCTURAL. REFORM OUT WITH
THEIR SAID IN A DIFFERENT
MODERATE ABOUT THE YOU CAN COME
UP WITH A- AND ARE. WHETHER
THERE IS ANY- TOTAL EVALUATION
KNOCKED OUT ALL DATA FROM
OUTSIDE DEMOCRAT A. B. A JACKET
HAS- DONE ANY REVIEW OF YOUR
AGENCY AND I MADE THE
RECOMMENDATION SO THAT WOULD BE.
MY RECOMMENDATION INSTEAD OF-
TRYING TO- CONTINUE- THE BUREAU
AS YEARS OF WHICH IS SO
STRUGGLING IN A SOUND LIKE A
VICIOUS CYCLE- BUT THE HIGHER.
THE PRIVATE SCHOOLS SUCH ARE
ATTRACTIVE SURVIVE AND THAT
THEY CANNOT AND THEY KEEP ON
CLOSING AND THE REVENUE COST
OUR OWN AND YOU KEEP ON RAISING
THE FUNDA HOW LONG. WILL IT IS
A VICIOUS CYCLE WILL CONTINUE
AND EVENTUALLY SB ALL MAY NOT
BE- YOU KNOW SARPANCH STAYS ARE
WANT AND IN THE FUTURE SO THEY
WERE I THINK A HAS TO BE WISE
TO HAVE. SOME BASIC EVALUATION
OF ALL FINANCIAL FOR THE FUTURE
LONG RUN- THE HIS- BETTER ARE.
THE MY- WAS. AND THE THAT'S MY
FOR ONE. AND OUR SECOND THEIR
QUESTION IS- IF OF MORE SCHOOL
WERE SO CLOSE AND THE MORE
VICTIMS STUDENTS OF. ARE BEING
FORCED TO LEAVE BEHIND WHAT
KIND OF A- BACK UP SO DO YOU
HAVE A RECOMMENDATION AS TO
WOULD YOU HAPPEN FOR THE
STUDENTS OF WHAT TO DO. LET OF
THE SCHOOLS ALL FULL. THEIR
FIELD MAY BE DIFFERENT BECAUSE
OF THEIR AUTHORITY HIGHLY.
SPECIALIZED TO SCORES ARE NOT
GO MEDICAL OR NURSING. WHAT
TECHNOLOGY SO SOME OF THE
SCORES AND MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
ABSORB WELL FOR STARTERS. AND
THAT THERE MAY BE. ONE IN
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA SYMON ONE
FOR THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
THE GEOGRAPHIC FACTOR MAY NOT
BE ABLE TO ABSORB THEM BECAUSE
OF THE DISTANCE. SEOUL ARE.
YOU'RE FREE INCREASE OUR- HOPE
WOULD NOT. FORCE THEM BUT THE
MAY IN FACT THE NEGATIVITY IN
SUCH A MANNER SO WHAT KIND OF
OPERATIONS YOU HAVE SO THAT'S
MY SECOND. QUESTION SINCE I'M
ASKING LET ME JUST OF PRODUCT
ON THE QUESTION. NUMBER THIRTY
IS THAT AMONG THEM MATERIAL
THAT OUR HEROES AS A EXEMPTION
SHUFFLE RELIGIOUS SO. OUR
INSTITUTION IS A AND IF THAT
THE CONTINUOUS SO THE EXEMPTION
SO DONE YOU WOULD REQUIRE MORE
THAN 50% OF- EACH COURSE MUST
BE. FOCUSED ON THE RELIGION OF
PER. YOU KNOW THOSE ARE THEIR
CURRENT. NEWS TO BE- RELIGIOUS
PRINCE FOR MORE THAN HALF OF
THEIR- I'M IN UP TO ME GREAT.
OUR AMONG MANY PHOTO ON. THIS
OF SAID THEY NEED TO ON. IT
THOUGH THOSE SOME MIGHT HAVE
BEEN ESTABLISH BY NONPROFIT
OPEN. OR GROUP- FOR THE OPEN TO
MEET MISSION BUTTON ON THE NEED
TO BE SEVEN HOURS. THEY A
VEHICLE MISSION MAY BE IN ORDER
TO ROUTE TO A TRAINED HIGHLY
TECHNICAL. MODERN TECHNOLOGY
BUT THE A FOR OUR CITY OUR
FOUNDER AND YOU FORCED ME OUT
TO TEACH A MORE THAN HALF OF
THE CURRICULUM ON RELIGIOUS
PRINCIPLES THEN THE DIRECTOR OF
THE PROGRAM WOULD BE AIRPORT
ALONG THE AND IT'LL BECOME
IT'LL- IS MUCH MORE EXPENSIVE
SO WITNESSES. ARE 50%
REQUIREMENT COME FROM I THINK
OF THAT HAS TO BE- IN ORDER
AMONG. THIS MESSAGE SIX SEVEN
DIFFERENT OFF COURSES SO YOU
KNOW DAY YOU TEACH ACTING ONE
SESSION. ARE IN THE RELIGIOUS
OF PRINCIPLE STYLE MIGHT BE
ENOUGH FIND THE STEERER
TEACHING THE BIBLE IF THAT'S A
CHRISTIAN SCORE I'M SHORE SO
THAT IS SAW. ARE THE RELIGIOUS
SCHOOL BECAUSE- NOR DOES SCORES
OR TEACH SUCH AS SUCH A
RELIGIOUS OF PRINCIPLE BUT OF
IT IS THE LACK OF SUPPRESSING
RELIGIOUS ORGANIZATIONS ON. NOT
TO SURVIVE OR NOT TO START.
SUCH A POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
IN A BY THE RELIGIOUS
ORGANIZATIONS SO THAT IS OUR-
BUT TO ME. FOR NO UNKNOWN
REASON SUPPRESSING
DISCRIMINATION OUR AND ARE OWN
SCIENTIFIC REASON WHY DOES IT
HAVE TO BE 50% OFF ON THEIR
CURRICULUM HAS TO BE RELEASED
PRINCIPLE. THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR ALL OF YOUR QUESTIONS- I'LL
GO IN ORDER AT THAT THE WAY YOU
BACK THEM. SO THE FIRST ONE I
THINK YOU WERE TALKING ABOUT
WHAT SPECIFIC TO AND HOW WE
LOOK AT THE STRUCTURE OF THE
FEES ADD- AT THE END OF STUDY
SO YEAH WE HAVE ACTUALLY. OUT
THEY PART THAT THE PART THAT
BUT WE BROUGHT IN A THIRD
AGAINST HE THAT I PERFORM EVERY
UP THE THAT BUREAU AND IN
CURRENT FACTOR AND THE THAT BE
A SAID IT CHARGING. LOOKING
WHAT THE EXPAND. WERE AND THAT
COULD NOT THAT HE SAID HE IS
THE RECOMMENDATION- YOU HAVE A
SIGNED UP IN THE BACK. PAPER
I'M FROM THAT. IT WASN'T
OUTSIDE PARTY IN. WHAT THE
BUREAU IT FELT. I THINK MEN AND
GET A AUDIT AND LOOK AT THE-
THAT WE- THE NEXT. THAT THE
BUREAU AND THAT WOULD RECKON.
THAT THAT BE THE YOU HAVE IN
YOUR- YOUR- THAT. I'M WITH THE
IN. THAT THEY BACK. I'M HOWEVER
WHEN BE. AND WE LOOKED. THAT
THE STATE AND WE LOOK AT BACK
OF. AND THINKING ABOUT WHAT
KIND OF THE THING IS IF THEY.
THE THING OF ALL IN THE- THOUGH
THE WAVE. WE CALLING THESE BE.
WE HAVE THANK IN FACT WE DON'T
WANT PEOPLE TO HAVE TO CALL
JUST BECAUSE THEY- PAY BUT
BUREAU FEES. AND THAT'S WHY OUR
SECOND RECOMMENDED KIND OF. IT
QUESTION A LITTLE BIT IN
LOOKING AT- STANDPOINT WHAT
OKAY WE DO AT MANTA WE GOT OUT
THERE. THAT PEOPLE WE ARE- AND
I. SAY WE'VE CAUGHT THE IT.
AFTER EXPENDITURES AND REVENUE
AND SEE IF THERE ARE DIFFERENT
FUNDING FOR WORK THAT NEEDS. TO
HAPPEN HERE IN A DIFFERENT
METHOD THAN WHAT IS CURRENTLY
GATHERING. I'M THAT WILL BE
VERY DIFFERENT WAIT COULD GET
AND WE'VE ALREADY BEEN STARTED
OUT OF THOSE DISCUSSIONS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS THAT. AND WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO CONTINUING
THAT IN THE FUTURE. BUT THAT'S
IT IN REGARDS TO YOUR FIRST
QUESTION WE GOT YOUR BACK FIVE
AND JUST LIKE WITH ANY SCHOOL
CLOSURE ADAM AND I GOT BEHALF
MR ABOUT WHERE THEY TALK A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THIS AS
WELL. BUT JUST LIKE WITH ANY
SCHOOL CLOSURE AGAIN OUR GOAL
IS NOT TO RAISE THE FEES THAT
HAVE VEHICLES WELL. I'M A
CURRENT- WE DO HAVE A PROCESS
OF REACHING OUT TO THOSE
STUDENTS AND IF THEY THINK THEM
THROUGH THE PROCESS THAT I WENT
AND TALKED. A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT. IN ABOUT MAYBE A LITTLE
HIGHER LEVEL. THANK YOU TO
THANK YOU FOR THE CALL- YEAH I
THINK I THE QUESTION. AGAIN THE
FACT THE LOCAL. OF THAT IF
SCHOOLS WERE- THERE. BEGAN TO
BE A TREND SCHOOL CLOSING
BECAUSE OF THE IMPLICATION OF
FEET INCREASE IT. IS REALLY A
QUESTION ABOUT YOU KNOW THE
QUESTION ABOUT HOW WE WOULD
ADAPT. THE QUESTION AOUT HOW
THE SECTOR ITSELF I THINK WHAT
IT DOCTOR AND IF IT IF THE
SECTOR HAS PROVEN BASED ON
HISTORY COULD BE PRETTY
ADAPTABLE TO DIFFERENT
SITUATIONS WHETHER IT BE.
EMERGING JOB MARKET OR NEW
TYPES OF TRAINING TECHNOLOGY-
MOVES TO APPLICANTS EDUCATION-
A LOT OF FOR PROFITSCHOOLS
THAT HAVE HAVE ENTERED INTO
CLOSE PARTNERSHIPS WITH LOCAL
WORKFORCE. BOARDS TO SORT OF-
MAKE THAT EXPLORER YOU KNOW
LIKE WHAT WHAT'S THE BEST
POSSIBLE TRAINING FOR THE
NEEDS- LOCALLY AND IN A
SITUATION LIKE THAT IF THAT
WERE TO BE IMPACTED I TRUST
THAT- THAT THOSE. BUT THOSE
DISCUSSIONS WOULD HAPPEN AND-
WHETHER IT BE- YOU KNOW
DEVELOPING NEW PROGRAMS
PARTNERING. WITH OTHER ENTITIES
THAT HAVE PREVIOUSLY PROVIDED
THAT PROGRAM- THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES I KNOW HAVE HAD A
LARGE INVESTMENT IN AKURE
EDUCATION PROGRAMS I'M SURE
THEY WOULD HAVE A VITAL ROLE IN
THAT AS WELL. AND AS IT RELATES
TO ASK OUR ROLE WOULD BE IN-
STAR WOULD BE THE LIAISON OF
THAT INFORMATION AND WE WILL
HOPEFULLY BE- PROACTIVELY SORT
OF PREPARING AND INVOLVED- AT A
HIGH LEVEL IN TERMS OF. THAT
POSSIBLE IMPLICATION THAT
YOU'RE REFERRING TO. AND THEN
BE PREPARED TO RESPOND. TO A
COMING OUT WHICH PERSPECTIVE.
AND THEN REGARDING YOUR LAST
QUESTION I'M IN A PATH ABOUT
THE METRIC READY TO TALK ABOUT
I'M THE RECOMMENDATION FOR THAT
RELIGIOUS EXEMPTION AND THAT
FIFTY PERCENT. AND AT THE END
OF THE DAY IT REALLY IS TO MAKE
SURE THAT- THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE WHEN THEY PASSED
THAT THE ORIGINAL LANGUAGE.
ACTUALLY IS WHAT WE ARE MEETING
AND WHAT THOSE SCHOOLS ARE
MEETING AND THAT WE'RE NOT
ACCEPTING SCHOOLS THAT
SHOULDN'T BE SO. I'M WANTING TO
MAKE SURE THAT HE- EXPENSE THAT.
YEAH YEAH THE WAY THE CURRENT
LAW IS WRITTEN IT BUT- THAT THE
INSTRUCTION IS LIMITED TO. THE
PRINCIPLES ABOUT RELIGIOUS
ORGANIZATION. BUT THE BUREAU IS
UNCLEAR ON WHAT THE LIMITED. TO
THE PRINCIPLES IS. IT AB WHAT
PERCENTAGE OF THAT- WHAT WHAT
DOES THAT REALLY MEAN WHAT IS
THE INTENT OF THE LEGISLATORS
FOR THAT. THE WAY IT'S
CURRENTLY WHAT YOU CURRENTLY
WRITTEN AND ALLOWS A RELIGIOUS
ORGANIZATION. TO OFFER
INSTRUCTION COVER ANY AND ALL
AREAS WITH VERY LITTLE-
REFERENCES TO THE PRINCIPLES OF
THAT RELIGIOUS ORGANIZATION.
THEREFORE STUDENTS. MAY RECEIVE
INSTRUCTION IN ANY SUBJECT WAS
BARELY A MENTION. OF THE
PRINCIPLES ABOUT RELIGIOUS
ORGANIZATION SO WE'RE REALLY
JUST LOOKING AT. HOW WE CAN
ENSURE THAT WE ARE IMPLEMENTING
THIS EXEMPTION AND. THE INTENT
OF THE LEGISLATORS. AND ALL
JUST SURE THAT WE PUT THOSE
STUDENTS IN FOR THOSE-
FACILITIES AND INTO THOSE
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS AND MAKE
SURE THAT IF IT IS AT AN
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAM THAT NEEDS
MORE OVERSIGHT BY THE BUREAU
THAT THEN THEY YOU NEED TO GET
THAT APPROVAL AND BE APPROVED
BY THE BUREAU. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL GO DO-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON FELL BY
CHAIR ROTH THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND JUST SO I CAN GO ON
RECORD ADD COMMENT ON- THIS
LAST QUESTION THAT WAS
ADDRESSED. A SLIPPERY SLOPE FOR
A GIRL TO START DECIDING WHEN-
AND INSTITUTIONS RELIGIOUS
ENOUGH. AND THERE ARE OTHER
WAYS THAT WE CAN DETERMINE
WHETHER OR NOT AN INSTITUTION
IS A FIVE OH ONE C. THREE. NON
PROFIT OR IS RELIGIOUS AND- TO
START MEASURING WITH
PERCENTAGES- TO ME IS A
DANGEROUS GROUND AND I'M- VERY
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THAT. I
THINK IF IT IS LISTED AND
RECOGNISED AS A RELIGIOUS
INSTITUTION THAT SHOULD BE GOOD
ENOUGH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ZHOROV. A RESEARCHER I YOU KNOW
I HAD MY- STAFF PULL THE- JOB
PLACEMENT FORM OFF OF YOUR
WEBSITE. I JUST TO TAKE A LOOK
AT IT I JUST HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS HOW TO THE SCHOOLS
COLLECT THIS DATA. AND WHO
COMPLETES THE FORM. EACH SHARE
AD OUR OUTSIDE PAY AND FOR
THEIR SENATOR ROB AND THEN PASS
IT UP. YOU WILL NEED TO ADD
ANYTHING- EACH YEAR EACH SCHOOL
HAVE TO PROVIDE ANNUAL DATA
YOU'D BE- ZERO- GETS REQUIRED
AT THE END OF THAT FOLLOWING
YEAR SO THEY WORK ON IT DURING
THE POST LIKE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THEY WORK ON THAT DATA
DURING TWENTY TWENTY AND THEN
IT'S REQUIRED THAT THEY PROVIDE
IT- BY THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY
SO ALL ABOUT YOUR PROVIDED. BY
THAT WELL WHAT ABOUT. AND WHERE
DOES THE DATA COME. IT DECADE
IT COMES FROM THE INSTITUTION
MY UNDERSTAND THAT BECAUSE THEY
SUBMIT THE FORM THE WORD IS THE
INSTITUTION GET THE DATA IS IT
A STUDENTS SURVEYED TO THEY GO
TO THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT OR SOME OTHER
GOVERNMENT AGENCY TO PULL
EMPLOYMENT DATA MATCHED TO
SOCIAL SECURITY NUMBERS OR- I
TENS. IT IS A SURVEY THAT THEY
DEAL WITH THE STUDENT AT THAT
POINT. DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE
RESPONSE RATE IS PER
INSTITUTION WHEN THIS
INSTITUTION SENDS OUT. A
STUDENT SURVEY. I DO NOT HAVE
THE SPECIFICS AND HERE WITH ME
AT THIS TIME. GET THAT
INFORMATION YEAH IS THAT DATA
THAT'S NOT ON THE FORM SO IS
THAT DATA THAT'S- COLLECTED BY
THE BUREAU IN SOME OTHER
FASHION SPECIFICALLY THE DATA
ON THE STUDENT. RESPONSE RATE
REGARDING POST GRADUATION
EMPLOYMENT. THE FISCAL THE
REQUIRED TO KEEP THE BACKUP
DOCUMENTATION FOR THESE
REPORTS. AND THE BUREAU
PERIODICALLY DOES AND CHECK ON
THOSE REPORTS SO THE BUREAU HAS
ACCESS TO THAT DATA- TO DOUBLE
CHECK IT WELL I WAS GOING TO
ASK IF YOU WANTED THE DATA. TO
ENSURE THE ACCURACY OF THE
REPORT SO LET ME FOLLOW ALONG
WITH THAT SO THEN IF WE- AS
EITHER A JOINT COMMITTEE OR THE
SENATE COMMITTEE REQUESTED DATA
ON THE SCHOOLS WITHIN YOUR- THE
PURVIEW OF YOUR OVERSIGHT. AS
TO THE RESPONSE RATE. PER
INSTITUTION WOULD YOU HAVE THAT
DATA. I'M SORRY CAN YOU PLEASE
REPEAT THAT LAST PART OF THE
QUESTION WELL I'M TRYING TO
FIND OUT IF STUDENTS GET JOBS
AFTER THEY GRADUATE AND YOU
SAID YOU HAD A FORM AND I
PULLED THE FORM. AND I ASK WHO
COMPLETES THE FORM IT'S THE
INSTITUTION I ASK WHERE THE
INSTITUTION GOT THE DATA GETS
THE DATA AND YOU SAID FROM THE
STUDENTS IN A SURVEY. I ASK
WHAT'S THE RESPONSE RATE WHEN
THE INSTITUTIONS SEND OUT
STUDENT. SURVEYS WHICH SHOULD
BE RELEVANT. AND NOW I'VE ASK
YOU DO YOU KEEP TRACK BY
INSTITUTION OF THE STUDENT
RESPONSE RATE WITH RESPECT TO
THE- POST GRADUATION. JOB
SURVEY AND MY POINT IS THIS.
GIVEN INSTITUTION PROVIDES A
REPORT BASED ON A STUDENT'S
SURVEY AND TEN PERCENT. OF THE
STUDENT GRADUATES RESPONDED I'M
NOT SURE. HOW VALUABLE THAT
DATE IS AND SO MY QUESTION TO
YOU IS. IN YOUR AUDITING IN
YOUR REVIEW DID YOU DETERMINE
HOW ACCURATE. AND VALUABLE THIS
DATA IS IF WE'RE IF WE BOTHER
TO COLLECTED. SO CURRENTLY WE
DO DO SPOT CHECKS ON THAT DATA
IN AS PART OF THE INFECTIONS
THAT WHAT YOU DO. HOWEVER AND
WE BELIEVE THAT THIRTEEN FORTY
IS DEFINITELY GOING TO HELP IN
THIS MATTER WHERE WE'RE GONNA
BE ABLE TO MATCH THE DATA WITH
EDT TO GET MORE ACCURATE
INFORMATION. WELL I CERTAINLY
HOPE SO AND SO IN THE INTERIM
WHAT I'D LIKE TO HAVE COMING
TOWARD. AT LEAST THE SENATE
SIDE OF THIS JOINT COMMITTEE.
IS A REPORT ON THE AVERAGE
STUDENT RESPONSE RATE IN THE
INSTITUTIONS THAT YOU'RE
RESPONSIBLE FOR REVIEWING WITH
RESPECT TO THE POST GRADUATION.
EMPLOYMENT DATA. AND THEN WE'LL
SEE IF WE NEED TO. TURN THIS
ISSUE UP A LITTLE FURTHER. OKAY
I APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU SIR
THANK YOU THANK YOU MISTER.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IN THE
CHAMBERS AT THIS TIME. C. OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOI. OKAY LET
ME ADD ONE MORE QUESTION THAT
IS REGARDING THE TWO TRACKS OF
ALL APPROVING ONE IS- THROUGH-
RECEIVING OUTSIDE ACCREDITATION
AND THE OTHER ONE IS A FULL
APPROVAL HI- OF GAS SO THAT IS
A FULL APPROVAL THROUGH- A B.
P. P. E. N. I WOULD LIKE TO
KNOW IF YOU HAVE A SUCH A DATE
OFF- WHAT PERCENTAGE. OF ALL
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS ARE ARE APPROVED
BY ACCREDITATION AND- THE- THE
RULES BORDER- REVIEW AND-
RELATED TO THAT- OUR SAID
THINKING IF YOU ARE. A. B. P.
P. HE CONDUCTS A FULL ORDER-
APPROVAL PROCEDURE ABOUT WERE
TAKE TO YOUR STAFF TIME AND A
LOT OF WAY EXPENSES SO AND. THE
LENGTHY PERIOD GO. I WONDERED
THE- THE METHOD OF ALL.
APPROVING THROUGH ACCREDITATION
MAY SAVE- YOUR BEERUS COSTS ARE
IN THE FUTURE. THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY AND- FIVE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY ONE OF THE SCHOOLS
THAT HAVE A FULL APPROVAL AND
THE FINALLY FOUR HUNDRED TWENTY
SEVEN THAT HAVE THE APPROVAL BY
MEANS OF ACCREDITATION. AND
ALTHOUGH THE COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH THE APPLICATIONS ARE QUITE
DIFFERENT TO THE APPROVAL BY
MEANS OF ACCREDITATION OF A
MUCH LOWER COST AS WE'RE NOT-LOOKING AT THE INFORMATION THAT
WE LOOK AT ONE OF FOR A FULL
APPROVAL FOR THE BUREAU HAS
FOUND THAT- MANY TIMES WE'RE
FINDING THAT THE APPROVAL BY
MEANS OF ACCREDITATION SCHOOL
WHEN WE GO OUT TO DO
INSPECTIONS ARE WE GET
COMPLAINTS. THAT THEY ARE NOT
PROVIDING THE PROPER STUDENT
DISCLOSURES ARE SOMETIMES EVEN
IN A ROMAN AGREEMENT TO THE TO
THE STUDENT AT THE TIME THAT
THE STUDENT ROLES WHICH ARE
PART OF THE OUR MINIMUM
REQUIREMENT THAT THAT THE STATE
HAS FOR THE SCHOOL SO WHAT WE-
THE REASON REALLY BEHIND THIS
IS TO. ENSURE THAT THE THAT THE
INSTITUTIONS ARE. FOLLOWING THE
CALIFORNIA REQUIREMENTS. FOR
APPROVAL VERSES THE ACCREDITOR
REQUIREMENTS AND THAT WE'RE
INSURING THAT THE STUDENTS ARE
GETTING THE PROPER DISCLOSURES
UP FRONT AND THAT THEY HAVE AN
ACTUAL ENROLLMENT AGREEMENT
THAT. PROTECTS THEM IN WITH ALL
THE DISCLOSURES THAT ARE
PROVIDED- THIRTY WE UNDERSTAND
THAT THE COST WOULD DEFINITELY
BE- MORE AND IT WOULD BE MORE
WORK FOR THE BUREAU- BUT IT
WOULD BE MORE WORK IN THE FRONT
END VERSUS THE BACK END SO WE
THINK IT'LL- AND EVENTUALLY
BALANCE OUT AND IF WE DO IT IN
A PHASED IN APPROACH. OR EVEN
IF WE MODIFY IT VERSES- NOT
GETTING RID OF APPROVAL BY
MEANS OF ACCREDITATION
COMPLETELY THAT MAYBE MODIFY IT
WHERE WE CAN REQUIRE THAT WE
RECEIVE MORE INFORMATION UP
FRONT CATALOGS AND ROAMING
AGREEMENT FINANCIAL STABILITY
IN THOSE TYPE OF THINGS. I HOPE
THAT HELPS ANSWER YOUR QUESTION
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS COMMENTS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
WILL TURN THE CONVERSATION BACK
TO PUBLIC COMMENT. IF YOU ARE A
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC. A PLEASE
BE REMINDED THAT. WOULD LIKE
YOU TO LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS TO
NO MORE THAN TWO MINUTES. A
SCENE NO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
CURRENTLY IN THE CHAMBERS AT
THIS TIME WILL MOVE TO. THE
OPERATOR OF KNOWLEDGE AND TAKE
A PUBLIC COMMENT. FOR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WHICH IS
TESTIFIED FOR THE BUREAU FOR
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION. WILL BE USING BE
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
AGAIN THE CALL IN NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS TWO FOUR.
TWO SIX. TWO THREE SEVEN.
OPERATIVE PLEASE WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. IF YOU WISH TO
MAKE PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
OUR FIRST COMMENT COMES FROM
THE LINE WITH YOU PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SERVICE
MEMBERS ARE BACK ON MARKET
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTRE FOR PUBLIC INTEREST LAW
CHILDREN'S ADVOCACY INSTITUTE.
AND THE VETERANS LEGAL CLINIC
WE SUPPORT THE MUCH NEEDED
REFORMS AFTER BUREAU FOR
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
PROPOSED BY BOTH THE GOVERNOR
AND BY THE COMMITTEES AND THE
ACT ON A NOW PREPARED FOR
TODAY'S HEARING. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. CONNECT COMMENT COMES TO
MIND TWENTY ONE PEOPLE HAD. YES
MY NAME IS REQUIRED I AM THE
PAST CHAIR AND CURRENT BOARD
MEMBER THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PRIVATE POST
SECONDARY SCHOOLS. LIKE TO
THANK THE CHAIRS OF THE
COMMITTEES FOR CONDUCTING THIS
HEARING AND FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
SPEAK TODAY. WANT TO BEGIN BY
ADDRESSING THE PROPOSED BPP FEE
INCREASES AND TO GIVE YOU SOME
PERSPECTIVE IN TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN MY SCHOOLS PAID THE
BILL TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
DOLLARS. AFTER THE RECENT
200-017-2000 EIGHTEEN FEE
INCREASES WE PAID NINETY THREE
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR 2100% PLUS
INCREASE. THAT WOULD BE AN
ASSET TO PAY AN ADDITIONAL
FORTY FOUR PERCENT. TO BRING
OUR FEES WELL OVER A HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR. IN ADDITION TO DC'S AS
HAS ALREADY BEEN MENTIONED WE
ALSO PAY INSTITUTIONAL
PROGRAMMATIC ACCREDITING
AGENCIES. AS WELL AS OTHER
STATE BOARDS. THERE ARE AN
ADDITIONAL TWENTY SEVEN OTHER
FEES OUTLINED IN THE PROPOSAL
THE INCREASES FOR THESE FEES
ARE STAGGERING. RANGING FROM
3100% OVER 13100% WE AGREE WITH
CHAIRMAN ROSS MR FONG MR CHOI.
BUT THIS MODEL IS SIMPLY NOT
SUSTAINABLE OVER TIME AND WE DO
FEAR THAT. MAY RESULT IN THESE
ADDITIONAL COSTS BEING PASSED
ON TO STUDENTS. ADDITIONALLY
WE'D LIKE TO- A STATE THAT WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE CONTINUED
USE OF THE STRIP FUN. BUT ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE RECENT
RETRO ACTIVE STUDENTS HE
INCREASE. STUDENTS IN
INSTITUTIONS NEED ADVANCE
NOTICE AND THE GIRLFRIEND
STRIPTEASE ARE GOING TO BE
COLLECTED. WE RECOMMEND THE ACT
BE UPDATED TO PROVIDE MORE
TRANSPARENT AND EFFICIENT
PROCESS. WE DO BELIEVE
DISCUSSES THE BEST WAY TO
MITIGATE. ANY HARM TO STUDENTS
THAT DOESN'T RESOLVE BY THE
INSTITUTION. FOR THE FEDERAL
STUDENT LOAN FORGIVENESS
PROGRAM. AND FINALLY I'D LIKE
TO ADDRESS THE PROPOSAL TO ADD
SECURITY BONDS. WE DO NOT
SUPPORT THE USE OF SURETY BONDS
IT'S A COMPLEX AN INEFFECTIVE
METHOD TO MITIGATE STUDENT
HARM. OR SCHOOL CLOSURE COSTS
THIRTY BONDS ARE DIFFICULT TO
OBTAIN. NEARLY IMPOSSIBLE FOR
NEW SCHOOL ENTITY TO QUALIFY
FOR. AND WOULD LIKELY BE UNDER
UTILIZED IN A MANNER SIMILAR TO
THE CURRENT STRESS. CAPS IS
LOOKING FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE AND CONTINUING
TO SEE IMPROVEMENT WITH THE PPP
THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE CAN.
SO I THINK I CAN MAKE. YES WE
CAN THANK YOU. HELLO OKAY BOOK-
HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER DEMAND
AND YOU GUYS MIGHT RECOGNIZE ME
IF YOU READ THE ARTICLE- THAT
WAS DONE AND I ENJOYED BY
CALMATTERS. IN THE DOCUMENT OF
THE- SO I ACTUALLY HAD A CASE
NUMBER WITH THE VP CASE NUMBER
ONE ZERO ZERO ONE SEVEN ZERO
FIVE. AND MY CASE WAS DISMISSED
BECAUSE- THEY SAID THEY HAD NO
JURISDICTION BUT I ACTUALLY HAD
A LETTER TO THE- TO THE
OPPOSITE- AND SO- I JUST WANT
TO READ YOU- KIND OF THE
RESPONSE FROM THE INDIVIDUAL
ENFORCEMENT INVESTIGATOR FROM
THE COMPLAINT INVESTIGATIONS
UNIT YOU CAN KIND OF SEE- THAT
I REALLY HAVE A PROBLEM WITH IT
PATTING THEMSELVES ON THE BACK.
CRAP ESPECIALLY GIVEN- THE WAY
THAT THEY'RE CONDUCTING
THEMSELVES SO- THAT THEY
INDIVIDUALS AND THANK YOU FOR
SUBMITTING YOUR COMPLAINT THE
INVESTIGATION IS COMPLETE THE
DEPOSITION LETTER ATTACHED FOR
YOUR RECORD- AND THEN I'M GONNA
READ YOU A PARAGRAPH OF THAT.
LETTER THAT WAS SENT TO ME
DURING THE INVESTIGATION OF
YOUR COMPLAINTS REGIONAL
RECORDS WERE OBTAINED FROM THE
SCHOOL AND IT WAS FUND THAT
YOU'VE GRADUATED WITH A
BACHELOR AND MASTER'S DEGREES.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVEN AND TWO
TWENTY ELEVEN DURING THAT
PERIOD YOU ARE ENROLLED AT THE
SCHOOL BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
FOREIGN TWENTY ELEVEN. THE
SCHOOL WAS NOT A BP GROUP'S
GOAL AND WOULD NOT REQUIRED TO
ADHERE TO THE CURRENT BP
STANDARD. ALTHOUGH NO EVIDENCE
FOUND AT THE SCHOOL GAUGED
INVOLVED IN THIS MEETING
ADVERTISING DURING THAT PERIOD
I HAVE TWO PROBLEMS WITH THAT
NUMBER ONE I HAVE A LETTER FROM
THE SCHOOL- WHICH I'LL READ THE
FIRST PARAGRAPH OF THAT LETTER.
THAT IMMEDIATELY CONTRADICT
THAT STATEMENT- DATA MARCH
NINETEEN. TWENTY TEN FROM BYRON
CHUNK IS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
ART INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA SAN
FRANCISCO. YOUR STUDENT ON
FEBRUARY FIRST TWENTY TEN THE
CALIFORNIA BUREAU FOR PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION. BTP
RESURRECTED THE STUDENT TUITION
RECOVERY FINE STR ASK MAKING
PARTICIPATION IN THE FINAL.
MANDATORY FOR ALL CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS UNDER ITS JURISDICTION.
THE US EUROPE IS A FUND
ESTABLISHED BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE LEGISLATOR. TO REIMBURSE
TUITION OR APPROPRIATE PORTION
OF TUITION PAID BY STUDENTS WHO
MIGHT OTHERWISE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF CHINA'S ARE DONE THANK
YOU EIGHT. IT'S UP TO YOU GUYS
BECAUSE WE KIND OF BEEN
PORTANTINO VERY MUCH IF YOU DO
YEAR. NEXT DEADLINE. TWENTY
FOUR. GOOD MORNING ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS AND SENATORS FRED JONES
WITH THE PROFESSIONAL BEAUTY
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA TRYING
TO GIVE VOICE TO THE OVER SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND LICENSED
PROFESSIONALS FROM WHICH THEY
PROVIDED US WITH A LARGE- I
HAVE THE UTMOST RESPECT FOR THE
DCA DIRECTOR BUT I'M AFRAID.
THE CA HAS BEEN ATTEMPTING
DEPARTMENTS TO COME UP BIG
TODAY. THE BJP BEING PRIOR TO
THAT THE P. P. P. P. P. PRIOR
TO THAT THE COUNCIL
INVITATIONAL EDUCATION HAS HAD
A LONG HISTORY OF INCOMPETENCE.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN THE
STATE AUDITOR GENERAL
RECOMMENDED BREAKING THEM UP
WITH FARMING OUT THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES THE OTHER T.
C. A. AGENCIES WITH SPECIFIC
INDUSTRY EXPERTISE. AND THAT IS
WHAT BRINGS ME TO USE TODAY
IT'S OUR STRONG RECOMMENDATION
THAT YOU ENDORSE THE STATE
BOARD OF PARDONS HOSPITALITY'S
OFFICIAL REQUEST. TO PUT SO
OVERSIGHT. OF OUR BEAUTY
COLLEGES HUNDRED ON. THEY
ALREADY APPROVED SCHOOLS. THEY
ALREADY DICTATE OUR SCHOOLS
CURRICULUM. THEY ALREADY
APPROVE OUR TEXTBOOKS. THEY
INSPECT. METICULOUSLY OUR
SCHOOL FACILITIES. AND OF
COURSE THEY PROVIDE THE LIFE
UTILITY THIS IS THE PRIMARY
PURPOSE OF WIRE STUDENTS ARE
ENROLLED TO BEGIN WITH. AND YET
THE STATE DEPARTMENT BECAUSE
WITH ALL THE CUSTOMERS ONE.
DIED FROM ANY OF OUR BARBARIAN
IF YOU DO SCHOOLS. HARRISON TO
THE EXORBITANT LICENSING FEES.
THAT FIVE FIFTY P. P. P.
PROCEEDS FROM THOSE SAME
SCHOOLS. OUR STATE BOARD HAS
THE INDUSTRY TECHNICAL
EXPERTISE AND FRANKLY ALL OF
OUR STUDENTS ONLY KNOW ONE PC
AID THIS THAT'S THE STATE FOR
BECAUSE AFTER LICENSES
AGENCIES. THEY DON'T KNOW WHO
THE P. P. P. P. S. THAT THEY
CALL IF THEY ARE BEEN TO FIVE.
THAT'S SO TO PROTECT OUR
BARBERING UT STUDENTS OUR
FUTURE LICENSE POPULATION WE
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF SO OVERSIGHT
AND SHIFTED FROM BTP. OUR HOME
STATE FOR THE PRIVATE
HOSPITALITY WHICH IS AGAIN IT'S
DEPARTMENT THANK YOU SO MUCH.
NEXT HEADLINE. NINETEEN HELLO
MY NAME IS THALIA THE CHECKER.
AND I WOULD HAVE THE ART
INSTITUTE OF CALIFORNIA SOME
TWENTY SIXTEEN START TWO
THOUSAND SIX HE TOOK OF MY-
ONE. OF THE SENATORS ASKED THE
QUESTION ABOUT. THE CAREER
CENTER AND ARE JOB PLACEMENT
I'D LIKE TO ADDRESS NOT. SO DID
YOU ALREADY DID YOU I WAS
EXTREMELY EXCITED. TO GET INTO
A SCHOOL THAT PROMISE. JOB
PLACEMENT IN THE FIELD THAT
YOU'RE GOING CRAZY R. J. CAREER.
WE WERE COMMENTS THAT ARE
EXPERIENCE WE CANNOT AS WORK
EXPERIENCE. IN REALITY WHEN
YOU'RE PREPARING FOR GRADUATION
YOU WERE SHOWN WHERE THE
JOBCENTRE WHAT AN OFFICE THAT
WAS MOSTLY LOCKED HORNS ON MAN.
IF SOMEONE WAS THERE FOR A BI
WE'RE INSTRUCTED TO CHECK
CRAIGSLIST OR ONLY WEAKLY ONE
AT. JOBS POSTED ON THE JOB
FORCE TO GRAPHIC DESIGNERS BUT
CASHIER POSITIONS THAT CHANGING
BACKS AND WALKS. IS ANYTHING
WITH HOSTED. ANY INTERNSHIPS
WERE UNPAID AND NOT IN THE
FIELD. AFTER GRADUATION IF I
WAS LUCKY ENOUGH TO GET A JOB
INTERVIEW HIRING MANAGERS TOLD
ME TO REMOVE MY EDUCATION. FROM
IRAQ AND- THAT'S NOT A REAL
SCHOOL. SO I WENT BACK TO
SCHOOL AND WENT BACK TO SCHOOL
A LITTLE MORE CREDITS IN
TRANSFER. I ENDED UP TAKING MY
COURSES AT A COMMUNITY COLLEGE
AND GOT MY EDUCATION TWICE. AND
TO ADD INSULT TO INJURY. WHEN I
GRADUATED FROM A. I. MY DIPLOMA
WAS WITHHELD AT THE LAST MINUTE.
GETTING MY STUDENT LOANS
CONSORT I HAD A BALANCE AND
NEEDED TO BE PAID BEFORE
RECEIVING MY DIPLOMA. I CASH
OUT MY VERY LITTLE FOR ONE K.
AT THAT TIME. FOR SEVERAL
THOUSAND DOLLARS I WAS ABOUT TO
RECEIVE MY DIPLOMA. WHICH
LEADERS WITHIN THE WORKPLACE HI
HIRING MANAGER. I CAN NOT GET A
JOB NOW THAT EVEN A GROUP OF
FOUR OH ONE K. THANK YOU. NEXT
DEADLINE. FIFTEEN THANK YOU TO
THE VARIOUS MEMBERS OF
COMMITTEES ASSEMBLED HERE TODAY
MY NAME IS SANKALP MEN AND I'M
THE HEAD OF INVESTIGATIONS IN A
SENIOR POLICY ADVISER AT THE
STUDENT BORROWER PROTECTIONS
CENTER NONPROFIT ADVOCACY
ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS TO
ALLEVIATE THE BURDEN OF STUDENT
DEBT MILLIONS OF BORROWERS
NATIONWIDE- THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK AND REYES
THE TERMS RELATED TO INCOME
SHARE AGREEMENTS WHICH WERE
MENTIONED IN THE BACKGROUND
DOCUMENT FOR THAT HEARING. AT
THE ISA MARKET HAS RAPIDLY
EXPANDED IN RECENT YEARS
WARNING ABOUT THE RISKS
INHERENT K. INCOME SHARE
AGREEMENTS HAVE GROWN LOUDER A
RANGE OF CONSUMER GROUPS
ACADEMICS LAWMAKERS JOURNALISTS
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS
ALL RAISE QUESTIONS REGARDING.
THE RIGHT. TO THESE PRODUCTS. I
REALIZE THAT I VERY LOS CALL
TRY TO GO THROUGH THE QUICKLY.
THE FOLLOWING ARE KEY AREAS OF
CONCERN RELATED DIET THEY IS.
THE PRODUCT TERMS ARE VERY VERY
RISKY. I HAD A COMPANIES
ADVERTISE THESE PRODUCTS TAKEN
STRAIGHT POWER BUT THE REALITY
IS FAR MORE COMPLICATED.
INSTEAD I IF IT CAN BE
EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE FOR
BORROWERS WITH A P. R.'S OFTEN
RANGING WELL ABOVE TWENTY
PERCENT. IN WAYS THEY CAN BE
HIDDEN- I TAKE CONTACT WITH A
LARGE PREPAYMENT PENALTIES. I
HATE GENERALLY INVOLVE ON
BREXIT MANDATORY FORCED
ARBITRATION CLAUSES- AND I
THINK OFTEN OF OTHER DUBIOUS
TERMS- SUCH AS MANDATORY
REPAYMENT OR AUTOMATIC AND- I
THINK IT ALSO PUT A SUBSTANTIAL
RISK OF FAIR LENDING
VIOLATIONS- NEED PRODUCTS ARE
OFTEN QUITE IN PART BASED ON
SCHOOL AND MAJOR THAT'S IN
BLACK. ALL OF ALL OF WHICH ARE
HIGHLY CORRELATED IN THE U. S.
THE FACTORS LIKE RACE AND
GENDER CREATING A SUBSTANTIAL
RISK THAT I ACTED COULD
CONTRIBUTE TO AND HELPED CEMENT
EXISTING DISPARITIES ACROSS
RACE AND GENDERS. AND ACCESS TO
CREDIT. FINALLY A DEFINING
FEATURE THE AYE AYE THIN MARKET
INDUSTRY THE THING OF THE
CONTRACT OR NOT STUDENT LOANS
ARE NOT EVEN CREDIT. AND THEY
THEY'RE FAR THEREFORE FALL
OUTSIDE LEGAL STRUCTURES AND
PROTECTION THAT BORROWERS RELY
ON FOR SAFETY IN THE MARKET.
AND THERE ARE REAL CONSEQUENCES
OF THIS RHETORIC AND IT SET A
TONE FOR INDUSTRY LAWLESSNESS.
AND PROVIDED A PRETEXT FOR AYE
IF THEY COMPANIES DIMINISH
BORROWERS RIGHT. JUST LAST WEEK
FOR EXAMPLE MY ORGANIZATION
PUBLISHED THE RESULT OF AN
INVESTIGATION CHOI THAT AYE IF
A COMPANY IS ASSOCIATE WITH
CODING BOOTCAMP INCLUDING
THOSE- THAT OPERATE IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN UNLAWFULLY
DEPRIVING STUDENTS OF THE
ABILITY TO PROTECT YOURSELF
FROM FRAUD. BY LEAVING KEY
CONTRACT TERMS THAT ARE LEGALLY
MANDATED AS DR INCLUSION. ON
THE DAY FEDERAL TRADE
COMMISSION FOLDABLE. DURING
KOBE BEEF ARE YOU GETTING A
MEASURE TO MAJOR. ADVERTISING
AGENCY. THANK NEXT HEADLINE. HI
MY NAME IS ASHLEY TO DUTY AND
IN EARLY TWO THOUSAND I WAS A
STUDENT AT NOW SHUTTERED BROOKS
INSTITUTE OF PHOTOGRAPHY.
ALMOST TWENTY YEARS LATER AND
STILL DEALING WITH NEVER ENDING
QUESTION STUDENT THAT. IN TWO
THOUSAND FIVE THE B. P. B. P.
B. HE WENT UNDERCOVER TO
INVESTIGATE ALL. SEVEN PAGE
REPORT DELIVERED CHAU STUDENTS
WOULD BEING DEFRAUDED ON OUR
JOB AND GRADUATION RATES
ACCREDITATION AND ACTUAL COSTS.
AS PART OF THE CONDITIONAL
APPROVAL TO OPERATE. CA.GOV HE
WAS OBLIGATED TO. COMPENSATE
ALL STUDENTS ENROLLED FROM MAY
TWO THOUSAND NINE R. MAY
NINETEEN NINETY NINE TO PRESENT
WHICH IS TWO THOUSAND FIVE AND
STOP AND ROLLING YOU STUDENTS
THIS IS NOT HERE IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN GONE OUT ON A
SMALL TECHNICALITY AND NEVER RE
OPEN. THIS I HAVE BEEN I THINK
THE LAST SIX YEARS ORGANIZING
AND COLLECTING ONE DATA ON
OTHER BORROWERS FROM THE
INSTITUTE I HAVE JUST. JUST
UNDER FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS NOW
FOR OVER SEVENTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS STUDENT AT AT FIVE
HUNDRED BORROWERS THAT- OVER
SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS IN DEBT
AT THE TIME. THIS IS ONE SMALL
P. E. C. OWNED FOR PROFIT
SCHOOL THE BPP BEEPS THAT PPP
HAS FAILED THAT. WOULD THERE BE
ANYONE BACK TO ACTIVE
ASSISTANCE BILLS BORROWED TO
THE. BEACH PP HAVE FAILED.
THANK YOU. NEXT HEADLINE.
TWENTY FIVE. HELLO MY NAME IS
ANGELA TERRY AND I'M A FEW OUR
POLICY IN AT THE INSTITUTE FOR
COLLEGE ACCESS AND SUCCESS- I
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
THOROUGH AND PRODUCTIVE
DISCUSSION DURING STATE HEARING
ON THE OPPORTUNITY TO ADD MY
COMMENT- BECAUSE WE NINETEEN
PANDEMIC COULD HAVE DEVASTATING
IMPACTS WORLDWIDE. AND
ESPECIALLY IN CALIFORNIA.
FULLER TO THE GRAY RECESSION
BIT ASKING ABOUT QUITE
TRIGGERED BY THE PANDEMIC IN
THE- RISE. YOU FONG. OF
DEREGULATION OF FOR PROFIT
SCHOOLS AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL IN
THE PAST THE OVERLAP OF AN
ECONOMIC RECESSION AT LEAST
POST SECONDARY EDUCATION
REGULATORY ENVIRONMENT HAS LED
TO. INCREASE IN ENROLLMENT AT
FOR PROFIT COLLEGES. AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE CAN ONLY
TRANSFER FOLLOWING THE SAME
PROBLEMATIC PATTERNS IN THE
LAST YEAR THERE HAVE BEEN
SIGNIFICANT DECREASES GOING ON.
A COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND OTHER
PUBLIC AND NONPROFIT
UNIVERSITIES WHILE THERE HAVE
BEEN GROWING. AT FOR PROFIT
COLLEGES. THREE WE WILL THAT RE
AUTHORIZED THE BUREAU IS THE
FACT IT FURTHER BELIEVE THE
BUREAU BE GIVEN BOTH THE- AND
CAPACITY THE VILLAGE. TO
PROTECT STUDENTS AND THE PUBLIC%
WE APPLAUD THE APPOINTMENT OF
MR COCHRAN AS- CHIEF AND
BELIEVE SHE WILL BE ADEQUATE TO
THE BUREAU AND FULL SERVICE
STUDENTS THAT CALIFORNIA. WITH
DEDICATION AND COMMITMENT. BUT
I SEEN IT IN THE TWENTY. EUROPA
ALL BE. TO HARM TO STUDENTS
PROVIDE. ACTIVE ACCOUNT
SURETIES BOND TO COVER THE COST
OF SCHOOL CLOSURES CREATE
STRONGER MINIMUM PROTECT
OPERATING STANDARDS YOU TERM
THE APPROPRIATE LEVEL OF
DEFERENCE TO ACCREDITATION THAT
ADDITIONALLY THERE APPROVED IT
SHOULD BE MADE TO THE STUDENT
TUITION OR COVERING FONG
PROGRAM THAT SHOULD BE REQUIRED
TO PREPARE STUDENTS FOR LIFE
INSURANCE PROFESSIONAL REQUIRES
IT AND THERE ARE NONE HE DIDN'T
MEAN NONPROFIT CONVERSION
PROTECTIONS THAT SHOULD BE
ATTRACT WE APPRECIATE THAT THE
COMMITTEE DISCUSSED. SOME OF
THOSE RECOMMENDATIONS TODAY
ADDITIONALLY ONE TOPIC THAT HAS
BEEN ATTACKED SEVERAL CRISIS
THE BUREAU'S NEW IT SYSTEM I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH YOU TOO
MANY THROUGHOUT ALL. THANK YOU
THANK YOU SO MUCH. NEXT
DEADLINE. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS RACHEL
BLEACHER NINE PROVIDING
COMMENTS ON BEHALF OF A GROUP
OF PSYCHOANALYTIC INSTITUTE
PSYCHOANALYTIC INSTITUTES ARE
UNIQUE AMONG OTHER PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY INSTITUTIONS
REGULATED BY THE BUREAU FIRST
THE INSTITUTE TO PROVIDE
CONTINUING EDUCATION AND
ENHANCE TRAINING TO LICENSE
PSYCHOTHERAPIST AND
PSYCHOANALYSIS SECOND THE INTO
INSTITUTES DO NOT ACCEPT
FEDERAL FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
FOR THEIR STUDENTS AND DO NOT
LEAVE STUDENTS WITH THE AN
UNMANAGEABLE DEBT. FINALLY THE
STUDENTS ARE SEEKING FURTHER
EDUCATION TO PROVIDE AN
IMPORTANT SERVICE TO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC TO ADDRESS MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES THAT HAVE ONLY
BEEN EXACERBATED BY COVERT
NINETEEN. I BOTH THE DEPARTMENT
OF CONSUMER AFFAIRS AND
COMMITTEE STAFFER AWARE
PSYCHOANALYTIC INSTITUTES HAVE
RELIED N THE STATUTORY
EXEMPTIONS IN EXISTING LAW TO
PROVIDE THEIR SERVICES.
UNFORTUNATELY IN THE LAST FEW
YEARS THE BUREAU HAD BEEN
LASTING CONSISTENT IN ITS
REVIEW OF APPLICATIONS FOR THE
STATUTORY EXTENSION WHICH HAS
LEFT MANY OF THE INSTITUTIONS
OF THE STATE OF LIMBO RELATIVE
TO THEI ALREADY TO OPERATE. WE
ASK THAT THE COMMITTEE
RECOGNIZE THAT THE LAW
GOVERNING OVERSIGHT OF PRIVATE
POSTSECONDARY INSTITUTIONS
INCLUDES AN EXEMPTION PROCESS
BECAUSE OF THE RECOGNITION THAT
SOME INSTITUTIONS ARE OFFERING
VERY SPECIALIZED EDUCATION TO
HIGHLY EDUCATED PROFESSIONALS.
BUT THAT'S NOT NOT THE STATE
RESUSCITATE THE LEVEL OF
OVERSIGHT NEEDED FOR OTHER
INSTITUTIONS. WE WILL BE
SUBMITTING PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
TO STATUTES GOVERNING EXEMPTION
TO CLARIFY THE APPLICATION OF
THE EXEMPTION THESE INSTITUTES
AND TO ENSURE CONSISTENCY WITH
THE ORIGINAL LEGISLATIVE INTENT
OF THE EXEMPTION. FURTHER GIVEN
THE UNIQUE NATURE OF THE
EDUCATIONAL OFFERINGS WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE FURTHER EVALUATION OF
THE INSTITUTE'S ABILITY TO
OFFER DOCTORAL DEGREES. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TIME.
THERE ANY FURTHER COMMENTS
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WHAT A LINE. TWENTY NINE. LINE
TWENTY NINE BUT YES MA'AM THANK
YOU HELLO MY NAME IS WENDY
COCHRAN AND I REPRESENT
LICENSED ESTHETICIANS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA UNDER OUR
GROUP NAME A CALIFORNIA SENATE
ALLIANCE WE APPRECIATE THE TIME
TO SPEAK TODAY. AS I LOOK AT MY
GROUP RESPONSES- WITH REGARD TO
THE SENATOR ROB STATEMENT ABOUT
HOW SCHOOLS DO OR DO NOT ASK-
REPLACEMENTS. I FIND THAT MANY
OF OUR RECENT GRADUATE UNDER
PREVIOUS GRADUATES OF THESE
PRIVATE SCHOOLS. DO NOT
ACTUALLY GET HELP WITH JOB
PLACEMENT IN OUR INDUSTRY AND A
LOT OF THEM FEEL VERY PRESSURED
BY THE SCHOOLS AND PRIVATE
INSTITUTIONS TO JUST GIVE THEM
AN ANSWER. SO IF THEY WERE
WORKING FOR A SALON OR- AND
FREELANCING FOR A SALON OR
BEING PAID UNDER THE TABLE BY A
SALON THEY'RE BEING PUSHED BY
THESE- THE SCHOOL PERFORMANCE
BACKSHEET. FINDERS TO ACTUALLY
JUST KIND OF GIVE THEM AN
ANSWER TO GET THEM OFF THEIR
YOU KNOW OFF THE CALL LIST- WE
REALLY FEEL THAT IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT- DEAD PDP. IT'S NOT
HOLDING OVERSIGHT OF THESE
SCHOOLS AS WELL- WE SUPPORT-
SHIFTING THE CONTROL OF THE
SCHOOLS OVER TO THE BOARD OF
BARBERING AND COSMETOLOGY
BECAUSE THAT'S THE AGENCY THAT
WE ARE REGULATED BY AND THAT'S
THE AGENCY THAT WE NEED TO WORK
WITH. IN ORDER TO IMPROVE THE
EDUCATION THE QUALITY OF
INSTRUCTION. AND THE PROGRAMS
THAT ARE PRIVATE CHOOLS. OFFER
US THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THIS
LINE. TWENTY SEVEN. HELLO CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN. OKAY-
HI- I'M BORED AND I AM IN THE
ADDRESS TO THE OFFICE SO- IT'LL
ALL HAVE A PART. MARTIN FOR
TAPPED OUT AND- THERE WERE.
FEELER IT RECENT YEARS THAT IT
IS REPORTED THAT THE DAY ARE
ISN'T REALLY DECLINE FROM DIRTY
TOOK THAT LIVE AMONG
APPLICATIONS- KADAVU ALONG-
THREE EIGHTY EIGHT AND
BACKSTOPS TO BACON FEDERAL
POLICIES THAT AIM TO INCREASE
ACTIVATION CHAPTER FIVE FIFTEEN
OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN REQUIRES THE
DESCRIPTION SHOULD ALSO RECEIVE
INFORMATION ON HOW TO COMPLETE
A FACTOR. CAL THE OB BEFORE
ENTERING HIS SENIOR YEAR I
THINK SEVEN DONALD DEFERRED
REQUIRE HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS TO
SUBMIT A PASSED OUT AT A
FEDERAL LEVEL AT LEAST WE
CONVERTED APPROPRIATIONS ACT OF
TWENTY ONE. LOSES THE AMOUNT OF
INFORMATION. REQUIRED OF
FINANCIAL AID. I TO FEDERAL.
THE NEW YORK MOST DECREASE THE
NUMBER STAFF THAT QUESTIONS
FROM ONE HUNDRED A THIRTY SIX.
THESE CHANGES ARE SCHEDULED TO
EFFECT IN THE TWELVE THIRD
TWENTY FOUR AWARD YOU'RE- THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSALS
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE WOULD
REQUIRE SCHOOL DISTRICTS COULD
FALL TO CONFIRM DEL HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS COULD BE FASTER OUR
CAT. I LET THIS TO CHOOSE
DROPOUT THE- DUE TO.
EXTENUATING CIRCUMSTANCES
DISTRICTS WOULD ALSO BE
REQUIRED TO DIRECT STUDENTS TO
SUPPORT SERVICES PROVIDED BY A
COMPLETE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION. ALSO KNOWN AS THE
STOCK AVERAGE PROGRAMS. PETER
QUORUM WOULD TO A BACK FOR
SENIORS IN THE TWENTY TWENTY
FIRST TWENTY. ONLY TWENTY
SECOND IN AFTER THE NEW YEAR.
TURNER BILL LANGUAGE PROVIDES
DISTRICTS WITH COMPLETE
DISCRETION ON HOW TO IMPLEMENT
QUORUM THE PROPOSAL HAS NO
ASSOCIATED FUNDING. THANK YOU
FOR LISTENING. NEXT DEADLINE
TWENTY AFFECT. HI THIS IS BOB
SHIREMAN I'M A SENIOR FELLOW AT
THE CENTURY FOUNDATION AND WHEN
IT THANK THAT COMMITTEE AND-
DCM THE BUREAU FOR THE-
THOUGHTFUL SUNSET REVIEW REPORT
FROM MORE THAN A YEAR AGO AND
THEN THE MORE RECENT- THOROUGH
STAFF REPORT- I SUPPORT THE
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT THE-
BUREAU BE AUTHORIZED TO BE ABLE
TO ADDRESS HARM A MORE
PROACTIVELY- THAT THE BUREAU-
BE AUTHORIZED TO ADOPT
ADDITIONAL MINIMUM OPERATING
STANDARDS AND I THINK THAT THE
ALREADY SHOULD BE SHOULD BE
FLEXIBLE AND NOT NOT
CONSTRAINED BY- BY ANY
LEGISLATIVE LANGUAGE- AND ALSO
TO ADJUST HOW ACCREDITATION IS
HANDLED IN. IN ADDITIONAL
APPROVAL- I THINK THAT- BUT
VARIOUS LINES OF QUESTIONING
THAT THEY HAVE- THAT WE'VE
HEARD THIS MORNING HAVE BEEN
RIGHT ON TARGET- THE QUESTION
OF- I'M NOT AN EXPERT ON THE
FEES BUT I THINK THE QUESTION
OF THE RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN
OTHER FEES AND- PRIORITIES-
HIGH PRIORITY SETTING ANDI
THINK THAT THAT THE NEW
LEADERSHIP OF- DEBBIE COCHRAN
COMING ON BOARD- IS- WELL
PREPARED TO HELP YOU THINK
THROUGH SOME OF THE QUESTIONS
THAT PRIORITIZATION- SENATOR
ROSS QUESTIONS ABOUT- ABOUT JOB
PLACEMENT HER RIGHT ON TARGET-
THE JOB PLACEMENT RATES. ARE
REPORTED BY SCHOOLS ARE NOT
TOLD NO TORIES FLEA UNRELIABLE-
AND NOT JUST BECAUSE SOME
SCHOOLS MIGHT NOT KNOW IT BUT
THAT MIGHT NOT BE HONEST BUT
BUT BECAUSE IT'S ACTUALLY VERY
HARD TO GET RELIABLE
INFORMATION THROUGH SURVEYS YOU
DON'T HAVE THE KIND OF RESPONSE
RATES THAT ARE THAT ARE NEEDED-
THIS GOES TO THE LEGISLATION
THE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOOSE
LEGISLATION FROM TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN- THAT ALLOWS FOR DATA
DATA MATCHING. TO ALLOW FOR
MUCH MORE RELIABLE INFORMATION
ABOUT EARNINGS AND JOB. BECAUSE
GRADUATION. SIMILAR A BILL WILL
PASS LAST YEAR THAT RELATES TO
THE QUESTIONS THAT CAME UP
ABOUT ARIZONA STATE UNIVERSITY-
ASHFORD AND OTHERS AND AT THE
SCHOOLS THAT MAY BE BASED OUT
OF STATE AND COMING TO
CALIFORNIA AND SAY THEY ARE
NONPROFIT OR SAY THAT THEY ARE.
OUR PUBLIC THERE ARE SOME
REFINED THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
CONNECT ABOUT ONLINE. TEN I
DON'T KNOW IF I'M ACTUALLY
ALLOWED TO SPEAK AGAIN I WANTED
TO ASK THAT PERSON IF I AM- IF
I CAN CONTINUE. BUT THANK YOU
FOR A PREVIOUSLY TESTIFYING
FEEL FREE TO SEND ANY OF YOUR
WRITTEN COMMENTS IN AN EMAIL
JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE
THAT ON RECORD. A BILL WILL
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT CALLER THEN
PLEASE THANK YOU. WHAT THE.
THERE ARE NO FURTHER QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEEING THAT
THERE'S NO ADDITIONAL COLORS ON
AT THIS TIME AND NO MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN THE CHAMBERS.
WANTED THANK THE- STAFF TO- ON
BOTH RESPECTIVE ON ALL FOUR
COMMITTEES TO. HELP PREPARE THE
ANALYSIS AND TO THOSE WHO
CALLED IN THIS RESPECT
CIVICALLY THAT OF THE STUDENTS
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WANT
TO ENSURE THAT WE HEAR YOU AND
WE'LL A TACKLE SOME OF THESE
ISSUES WITH DEEP EMPATHY. AS WE
VERY MUCH WELCOME YOUR
ENGAGEMENT AND THE PERSON
EXPERIENCES THAT YOU'VE HAD TO
THIS CONCLUDES OUR OVERSIGHT
HEARING FOR THE BUREAU FOR.
PRIVATE POSTSECONDARY EDUCATION
THIS MEETING IS ADJOURNED THANK
YOU.